[Music]
it's good to be back here i'm your host
patrick bett david
ladies and gentlemen we're live are we
really so you're the opening voice is
that what it is moving forward
did you just hire yourself walking
around restaurants bumping into women
pissing them off
and we got 135 watching today keep this
in mind that we're doing it on this
channel we are officially in florida we
want to tell what city we're in or we
can tell them what city we're we are in
boca raton
with our good friend who is back biz doc
aka tom ellsworth not the other way rock
biz doc
our guest today is my friend steve
murphy
we got gerardo gerard michaels
with us special guest adam's best friend
in the world ricky aguilar how you doing
i'm doing good how about you guys what's
up kevin
the one and only ronan
from call of duty aka two land we have a
special guest today michael francis we
have sammy double garvano here with us
today bernard carrick john styles david
harris jr how are you doing tom center
in the house
we have our good friend daniel de
martino here with us morning phil heath
just walks in come on infield i'm making
that's how you make it here you go the
one and only chance parliamentary aka
sunny the first thing
what is a soy boy
so i found
i found that out
[Music]
you should search that on youtube
instead of doing it here media not media
media yeah media matters oh kai from
norway t-h-u-r
kai t-h-u-r
oh my gosh kai just type in
you tell kai to taipei he types he's
sleeping
that's a great you said superman
unbelievable
guy epstein not eps okay it's gonna be
all right buddy
[Music]
happy birthday patrick
whatever prediction go the opposite
route
he said marilyn monroe was in bed with
bobby kennedy and she started yelling my
name
what are you smiling about it might
happen to you
they're chad's i can't i got kids i
totally understand that don't worry
about it you know i'm just a little
desperate right now call all five of
them seven of them up
and i asked them for money
boom as soon as i got to check they
couldn't ask me for money of course
you see this right here this is the crux
of all the issues gentlemen
this right here she's a latina from the
bronx ain't got no booty that is the
that's what's happening here
she needs to she wants to
be canceled don't do all the drugs now
later by the way like your opinion man
lincoln once said don't believe
everything you read on the internet
i don't know if you guys know that it's
very factual it's true
it's true
by the way youtube we're joking if he
came out and he was like they were like
why did you go to outer space and he was
like plus i could [ __ ] i've been like
this is the coolest dude on earth bye
bye bye bye
bye
[Music]
david tell us yes or no because it's
your turn
we are gentlemen we're live we're a live
100 episode we're doing this guys we
made it 200. we got biz doc in the house
tom ellsworth we got zen good morning
gerard michaels with an incredible
jacket by the way you brought that out
for today i found it at
is that in your pocket is that is that a
panties or what is that it doesn't look
like handkerchief okay that's good i'm
glad you brought that up
we got ricky ticio aguilar in the house
from
hey so this is a special event we're
gonna do this three hours okay this is
not gonna be a two-hour session this
will be a three-hour session let's do it
and this three-hour session that we have
here we got some giveaways we're gonna
give away a ps5 fully with the whole
joystick and all the additional stuff
that comes with it i think it's like a
thousand bucks we got some monte cristo
cigars we'll give away we got a brand
spank you know iphone 13. we may do some
special stuff signed books who knows a
lot of different things couple rules you
need to know is to participate in the
bigger giveaways
it's a 20 super chat if you participate
in the 20 super chat you'll be going
into the giveaway with uh uh uh the ps5
the iphone 13 the monte cristo who knows
maybe other things that will do as well
and by the way we may actually
have some of the people that are the
biggest super chats call in who knows we
may just have them calling until 100
podcasts so we got we got a lot of
things to talk about before we talk
about this adam i think
you go way back on this podcast no
is this a sentimental moment for you is
this an emotion like you're a guy i see
you cry a lot in your office all the
time
this is um
look you know they say that it's not
about the destination it's about the
journey and i remember we started with
podcast one before it was even the pbd
podcast
and uh enjoy putting in the work and uh
we've hit 100 000 subscribers 100
episodes we got the gang back gerard got
some panties in his pocket life's good
very impressive
george can we lower the audio a little
bit are you guys allowed on yours as
well or just me is it seems like a
little equity or no
you got me perfect much better so adam i
think one of the most common questions
everyone's asking me right now
uh from all over the place people around
the world want to know
how was that cat convention last week
was it was it as memorable as it was the
inaugural cat conference i mean gerard
you were gonna come with me but you
elected to stay here and work on uh you
know your special projects there'll be a
lot of uh put
there and and problematic situations i
think we're going on but look
some people are dog guys some people are
catman
i'm the cat daddy so
it worked out was it what you expected
though was it impressive it was actually
way too many men at the uh
can you tell by the way a bunch of super
chats coming in 20 bucks one
let me give some shout out here to
people
jesse jimenez juan garcia john just john
you know it's like madonna just one name
john gino avery jason uh rappy saterra
tbc racing 21 j mile high gave a hundred
bucks horrific scores gave 20. alex gave
50. holy moly it's on fire right now
enrique gave 20. jaime swatter is 20.
nabil gadzar gave 20. but but this is
this is the more important question
your mom actually followed the podcast
when i was taught my cat convention your
mom called you and said what my mom who
calls me 100 times a day
genuinely asked me look at the for the
record i was at a business conference in
dallas i can't
i can't leave but like
you have to clarify my mind that's
what's great no one believes
my actual mom is like what are you doing
at a cat conference i don't know you to
go to these things yeah mom i'm at a cat
conference
you're an embarrassment
yeah exactly
embarrassing i thought you were gonna be
a rabbi and now you're a cat conference
boy okay
but i i got a lot of love yeah at an
insurance conference
uh for being on valuetainment a lot of
insurance people follow the follow the
podcast follow you know you yeah that's
fantastic so you're going to be okay i
think you made them your mark in the
insurance world you said 20 years strong
and you're doing it in the insurance
industry yeah that's good that's a shout
out for you as well man last night we
did a small little uh show in in fort
lauderdale at gatsby's little comedy
show and uh pack through the roof man 75
in a in a 60-person venue all
valuetainers man got to give a shout out
to henry and ruggs especially our our
rigs i'm sorry rigs came out showed like
real love man valuetainers came out
strong in the gatsby's last night i love
the fact that when you go they show up
man to give you a lot when you're going
on doing your stuff they show up to give
you love no matter where you go i love
when the love is being given by tennis
like today my my my uber driver julio uh
nolasco from dominican republic
uh he said you know his last name yeah
because he gave me his card okay where
are you going i said i'm going to go do
i'm going to go do the uh the podcast
last name i know like come on bro you're
a human he's not a dog you know what i
mean like i know well they just show the
one name hector's picking you up
he gave me his card so anyway yeah he
wants you to start doing some deals that
makes makes sense how you vote so anyway
the point is this that uh
that
so he's dropping me off five minutes
[ __ ] go ricky
let's just [ __ ] bring it off he's
dropping me off and uh and uh he says oh
you know where am i taking you where am
i taking you i said attention to the
podcast well that was that was uh 13
years ago but he says uh that's not an
uber driver by the way that has a cage
in it uh but anyway it's a podcast he
knows
he's like oh yeah there's a oh because
he's talking about bernie sanders so we
were talking about politics and he says
oh you know bernie sanders says that uh
tax to rich and he's a millionaire guy
you know he's here from florida that i
follow since 2016 retweeted on myself
who is it and i already knew it was
yours oh you know patrick listen we were
talking i said actually where you're
dropping me off is we're going to do the
podcast he says no way it was pretty
cool so he's been following the contest
2016. he was telling me he's a dominican
republic uber driver private driver so
shout out to julio manning really cool
really cool guy that's all and it's good
for me people that follow the content
you know it's awesome yeah it's good to
hear here's the part though it's good to
hear
people who you would not expect to
believe in capitalism that believe in
capitalism by the way the echo is pretty
bad so i don't know what we're doing
about the echo which one is it where's
the echo coming from
uh uh tell us who it is david
doesn't sound as bad to the audience if
the audience is happy i'm okay that's
all i care about you're saying yes the
audience is okay okay it sounds like
we're coming to you live from your
garage
live from patrick's garage okay by the
way we've had a bunch of people already
give the 20 super chats i think i want
to do something right off the bat so uh
uh uh sam if you want to prepare it
before we get into the topics i want to
read some of the topics you prepared
some of that stuff for the uh uh super
chat and then after the first topic
we'll do the first superheroes yeah we
had a 50 we had a 50 in the super we had
100 we had a few 50s by the way some
people are putting 19.99 those are guys
who are on sale
[Laughter]
all right so here we go the stories that
we got first we got to cover what's
going on with meta facebook absolute
insanity because world is about to
change
dramatically it's about to change we're
probably going to talk about that a lot
american shrinking workforce a puzzle
for economist a math teacher
this is adam's favorite story is hosting
his lessons on pornhub yeah to market
his tutoring services for college
students that's how we found out about
the story adam was looking at some of
his courses and then he said let's add
this to the story scottie pippen
confirms he's furious with michael
jordan
right now dance shaq had a message for
his kids he says kids i'm rich we're not
rich not you
coca-cola uh buys full control of audio
for 5.6 billion dollars in its largest
ever brand acquisition i think paying
out kobe 400 million dollars zener did a
story on that on vtpost.com cigarette
sales increased in 2020 for the first
time in two decades i thought that would
have never happened they still make
those cigarette sales increase first
time in the last uh 20 years uh
fantastic whatever you guys did is much
better now
last night obviously with the governor
uh
republican glenn younkin who won
defeated terry mccollum mcauliffe in the
high stakes virginia governor election
we got a lot to talk about there i know
you got stuff to say about that george
got stuff to say about that marine
veteran winsome sears gave one of the
best speeches becoming the first female
and woman of color elected as virginia's
lieutenant governor
murphy inches ahead in jersey's tight
governor race which gerard is very happy
about former nypd captain eric adams
elected mayor of new york city
uh outrage at 400 vip jets
converge on
glasgow for global warming summit what
uh what an incredible noble people that
show up in their private jets pilot
under investigation for saying let's go
brandon you know i still don't know what
let's go random means but i don't know
if you guys know or not i still don't
know what it means during announcements
southwest airlines says treasury sector
secretary yellen breaks with biden and
says democrats should consider lifting
debt limit without gop help i don't want
to play chicken anymore and she promises
2.8 trillion dollars on spending
proposals will push inflation down biden
reportedly pooped his pants at the
vatican we don't know if this is
confirmed or not but gerard has some
sources that says this may have been
pretty accurate we'll have him share
that story with us elon musk warns
austin texas not to become like a
copycat liberal city in california city
considers offering the highest minimum
wage in the nation
can't survive it in and out burger in
florida cfo trying to entice them from
coming leaving california to come to
florida and i had some comments on that
and fortnite is shutting down in china
we may even talk about china it's
constructing
300 possible missile silos which could
make its nuclear arsenal bigger than
russia or america having said that let's
get into the first story
the first story is cigarette sales
increased in 2020 for the first time in
two decades if you want to go to page
four right there all right let me read
this too and we'll get into it uh rick
i'll come to you first with this one
cigarette sales increase in 2020 for the
first time in two decades more americans
bought cigarettes in 2020 according to a
report by the federal trade commission
the increase happened during the
pandemic stressors such as a pandemic
lockdowns remote learning and
stay-at-home lifestyles may have
contributed to the increase in tobacco
purchase according to the report
manufacturers sold close to a billion
more cigarettes in 2020 compared to 2019
cigarette use isn't the only thing that
increased the use of e-cigarettes and
vape pens increase in 2022 between
february 2020 and march 2021 e-cigarette
sales increased from almost 15 million
to 22 million units ricky what do you
got to say about this you know i have a
buddy of mine that's a smoker right he's
been a smoker for 10 years
and he went from smoking one pack a day
to smoking two packs a day because of
the stress he was under during in 2020
because he got laid off you know and all
that so uh that's one and then uh you
know
we're all human uh naturally i think in
2022 or i'm sorry 2020. um i had seen
the e-cigarettes i had never really paid
attention to them and uh and somebody
had them they're like oh it's like
cigarettes but it's not cigarettes right
i don't know i don't it has tobacco in
it that's the first time i had ever been
like curious about it because i'm not a
smoker you know um but even a person
like me i'm pretty i feel like i'm
pretty strong minded uh you you still
like you you try to find like a source i
mean i have you know i have adhd and i
don't have an aries so it's a bad
combination so you're always trying to
find a way to relieve stress so i i
totally can see apart from seeing it
firsthand with my friends and their
smokers doubling their smoking habits uh
even myself i'm like huh well because he
had told me the person that told me that
he said it helps you relieve stress and
i said wow that's that sounds like a
good idea but obviously you know it
didn't go down that route but just the
idea that is sport
just the spark itself i'm sure that out
of those billion new cigarettes not all
of them are are former smokers i'm sure
a lot of them are new smokers that
picked up the habit during the pandemic
from the stress let me ask you a
question all of you guys here how many
of you guys
no names how many guys know a lot of
people that smoke cigarettes yeah yeah
do you do you know yeah well especially
most people smoke cigarettes that i know
they smoke cigarettes after they're
drinking yeah you know you have a couple
drinks in you you go ahead outside you
have a dart you know what i mean and
that's that's how it goes and one of the
dark that's how you know you smoke some
cigarettes let me get a dark
dark never heard that so the uh
yeah the the
never heard that before the uh yeah so
you you don't like wake up in the
morning like you know in the movies and
you pop one i mean you're having a
couple drinks and what did everybody do
every day during the pandemic they got
they got drunk
everybody got drunk every day pandemic
well maybe not down here because we've
discussed this at length that you guys
really weren't all your friends in new
jersey were just getting drunk at home
yeah we were literally on house arrest
there was nothing else to do the only
things that were open were fast food
restaurants and liquor stores that was
literally all that was you come down to
florida you lose 50 pounds literally
there you go like actually literally
it's like florida
he doesn't realize other states exactly
no i don't know you know
i stay here ricky other people stay in
california you don't ask for the help's
last name i'm learning how many uber
drivers
let me ask you this you drive uber every
single day not these days how many
drivers last night do you know zero they
don't tell you their last name two ubers
this year how many ubers have you taken
can you name one
the only way to do it is to schedule
uber by the way with the cigarettes i
know i literally know more people who
have quit smoking than i know people who
actually smoke i'm with you
i don't see him smoking in the bars
california probably has a lot fewer
smokers here's the interesting thing
about this right the pandemic caused
this like gerard said 100 percent it's
the reason people are smoking more
but after you get that little buzz it
actually increases your anxiety and your
tension wait wait wait wait wait wait
wait wait wait are you saying smoking's
bad for you right no kidding right
here's the other fascinating thing about
this
part right smokeless tobacco increased
from
126 million pounds
to 129 million pounds they're measuring
this that's a lot of skull bandits
by the way i was in a gas station last
week and i saw two people back to back
come in and order chewing tobacco and
buy it
that's another thing you've never seen
anymore even baseball players i was in
florida yeah right when i was leaving
town so
i had a 15-year levi garrett habit for
sure did you i would imagine if you
played minor league baseball
fields
chewing tobacco's copenhagen's like god
yeah because you can't smoke close to
the wellhead so gerard can probably back
this up because you and i are probably
all the ones who hit the bars these days
these gen zers out there 18 21 25
whatever that age bracket the vape is
non-stop
like i'll look at a bar and they'll be
like boom boom boom just
vape it like remember back in the day
when there would be a club and a dj
would drop the beat and then smoke would
come out everywhere yeah of course
by the way is it illegal to show smoking
in movies can you not do that anymore i
mean maybe
you never see it anymore it's so funny
you watch those videos there's a stat
here that they didn't show because truth
has done a very good job of getting
people to stop smoking but there's
someone out there that has been probably
the biggest catalyst into smoking and
that's mats apollo this guy makes people
smoke cigars left and right i don't
throw some cigars with the money smart
guy
and six months then in ten years shout
out to matzo paul he makes it but don't
show it yet don't show it don't go down
to the bottom okay question for you
price of a pack of cigarettes today okay
i'm going to go i'm going to stay i'm
going to ask you i'm going to ask you by
state i'm going to ask you by stiff you
guys can stop interrupting each other a
little bit that'd be good all right here
we go
give me the price of cigarettes in new
york city one pack 12 bucks no
uh american spirits would probably be
like 19 between 19 and 21 bucks okay so
it's by the way
the fact that you know the number
concerns me a lot about just 12.85 okay
price of cigarettes a pack in illinois
1150 massachusetts 9.95 you can show it
now kai uh alaska's 979 vermont 962
hawaii 955 connecticut 952 washington
930 rhode island 895
wisconsin 8
82 for a pack of cigarettes if you're
smoking two packs of cigarettes a day in
california you spend 16 a day you're
spending eight bucks a day on cigarettes
here's one rule i have i this is going
to offend some people i don't do
business with people who smoke
cigarettes i just don't simple as that
you come to my house how long does it
take to smell cigarettes how long does
it take to smell it it's on their
clothes if i sense it i am buying i have
a very simple rule if i sense it i'm not
buying cigarettes the smell to me is
something shaking hands when you shake
hands with somebody else that hand that
that then you cough you go like this you
had an incident where you were going to
do business with somebody and you said
sorry buddy if i tell you 50 times
that's a small number 50 times that's a
small number but what do you mean what
type of business like a new age
you're selling me anything you're doing
with me i'll have the conversation i'll
say can you tell me why you smoke
cigarettes
everything has a reason smoking
cigarettes doesn't have a reason why do
you drink alcohol okay you get a little
bit tipsy maybe it gives you a little
bit of a buzz fine that liquid curd
smoking weed okay fine smoking
cigarettes there is no argument on why
anybody should smoke cigarettes but here
you go 2020.
people are supported stressed even the
french so you're not doing any business
with anybody the numbers really do
surprise me because
i'm okay
let me just tell you this story it's
already too late anyways so i'm dating a
a a former miss i'm not going to say the
state so we're dating this was a few
years ago
and we're going out one day we're going
out we kiss
that was the last time we kissed because
you smoked cigarettes
i cannot do that if i if i have any
smell with cigarettes i can't do it to
me i can't do it now you may call it a
weakness call a judgment say i judge
people whatever you want to call it i
cannot do cigarettes by the way another
pet peeve coffee stains you guys know
with coffee how i work
you have no idea for me to even think
about that thing sitting right there is
two inches away from dropping the stain
okay everything to me with coffee
cigarettes some some people may call it
crazy a little bit you know i ran sales
offices for 15 years without letting
coffee in there mario and the guys mario
can tell you the story at a sales office
in in by the way if you were in the
granada hills office you're listening to
the podcast you can post it in the
comment section to verify this or if you
were in northridge you can verify this
guys would put their coffees outside the
uh office like literally the door is
here the coffees will be lined up 10 of
them here they could be outside but they
could have been inside anyways i have
something about cigarettes and coffee it
is what it is maybe i'll start drinking
coffee
i can't relate to that though i mean
because that that takes you out of your
zone because if you got three people
doing it the same thing with me with
people chewing gum i can't deal with it
i freak out every one of you drinks
coffee my wife loves coffee my dad loves
coffee my sister loves coffee my own
kids say mom can i have a sip of that
coffee right me i'm good
did someone spill hot coffee on you no
there was a stain there was a stain
there was a stain at the granada hills
office that i would have to look at
every single day when i came in i can't
deal with snakes by the way you know who
drinks more coffee than anyone i've ever
seen in my life who our friend mario
this guy used to go 10 cups a day it'd
be it'd be midnight and he's ready for
bed he's like can i get a cup of coffee
to go it's insanity
why don't we do this espresso why don't
we do this what is the best coffee
machine
out there tell me what the best coffee
machine is
what's what's up no give me a coffee
machine to buy how much is a coffee
machine what's 300. can you pull up pull
up a coffee machine you're going to go
through
what is the best coffee machine this is
what happens when you put this out there
be careful with your choice because
pat's going to buy this it's an espresso
tell me what it is
what's the best coffee machine you don't
like espresso tell me one of the best
coffee machines give me a i'll give you
some a reason why because the computers
are inexpensive and it's good coffee not
keurig no french press man okay is that
the all-in-one is that a good coffee
machine is that the one which one that
makes you know like legit barista type
coffee but you don't want to do that go
with an espresso you push one button
okay xander knows his stuff about this
what's the deal with onions though
oh
don't get this man started on onion guys
great question everybody has a certain
gift one of my gifts is i'm gifted with
a big nose okay yeah which means i can
still smell stuff from a mile away
middle easterns
i know what they're doing across the
street right now i can smell it it's one
of those things
onions i come in david's having onions
i'm like what are you doing okay one
time robert our hr guy's having onions
he's trying to hide the onions i'm like
get that onion i feel bad so bad for her
carlos one time i think this was like
his second week he usually warmed up his
little lunch whatever pat comes storming
out his office onions who's got it
like coffees are big cigarettes on
onions as well i could never live next
to a starbucks that's right i'm sure
i'll take it i'll take it i'll take it
up one more
have first office php
dallas texas
we're in the conference room
we really screw up and we've lit pat up
okay you you and you my office we're
going to process this we're walking down
the hall and there's this little tiny
break room that was there remember that
the two little the one table and i think
and and paul s garciga
is
microwaving and reheating
fish from hell
and as we walk past the break room we
all thank god for paul
because he got distracted goes paul how
could you bring that in you of all the
things you could bring in the reheat for
your lunch you bring this in this is
horrible the stinks
and
suddenly we got to his office he was
there's a lesson here
you're in trouble with pat
like yesterday i was a little late i was
a little in trouble
just have someone show up with some
onions just calling from the bullpen get
an onion guy
kenny max
you're relaxing i got a meeting with pat
it's not gonna be a good meeting can you
do me a favor and order a chalupa with
an extra
onion guy
do you remember paul and the fish it's
like
ah
okay so listen you guys got me in a good
mood here's what we're gonna do we had
ten thousand live i'm gonna give ten
thousand dollars away to super chatter
okay so let me say that one more time
if we hit ten thousand live i'm giving
ten thousand dollars cash to somebody
that does twenty dollars on a super chat
so screw it we just decided this okay
this is what other tell your friends
have
if they've given twenty dollars i really
like the personal story you know people
have had some tough times this year i'd
like to know the personal story behind
the person that gives 20 bucks
yeah it'd be nice to help somebody that
needs a little bit we're gonna we're
gonna do some of that stuff maybe we'll
do it in the second half when we uh when
we keep going with this but that's a
good idea tom uh so
uh samville are we ready for the first
giveaway or no because i think the list
is a long list gang if you want to get
in there right now give your 20 super
chat we're going to do the first uh
uh giveaway do we do the monte cristo
why don't we do the monte cristo first
can i help you let's do the monte cristo
with a signed copy of uh of uh your next
five moves and i'll make it to the
person sam if you're ready
pull it out kai is pulling it up okay if
what is this thing explain what's going
on with this wheel this has everyone's
name in there that gave 20. right now
yeah
this is pretty dope
but they're not included
so you have this right now for the 27
people that are in there
yes okay all right let's do the first
one here so you're going to click to
spin it you click to spin it this is for
mono crystal cigars and a signed copy of
your next five moves and the winner is
jason
oh
three four zero one one three two to get
your box of monte cristo cigars and a
signed copy
of your next five moves outside of the
window
so they got to do okay okay that was
only for one giveaway yeah that's one
giveaway so
sambal it looks like you're behind with
names keep adding the names to it okay
first price is gone
we got it up here okay let's get into
that congratulations to jason
next next story next story let's talk
about scottie pippen confirms he's
furious with michael jordan after the
last dance how dare how dare the goat
offend scotty so scotty pepin confirms
his furious with michael jordan after
the last dance usa today's story pippin
said it was challenging for him to see
jordan constantly glorify while he and
his teammates were not given nearly
enough praise for their contributions to
the six title runs while pippin said he
wasn't surprised at the depiction and he
felt it would have been naive to expect
anything different being demand demeaned
once again was brutal because it was
insulting enough when it happened in
real time beyond the journalistic
integrity that vanished when the
producers gave jordan editorial control
of the final product pivot also felt
fiscally slighted as well to make things
worse michael received 10 million
dollars for his role in the dock while
many teammates and i didn't earn a dime
another reminder of the pecking order
from the old days for an entire season
we allow cameras into the sanctity of
our locker rooms our practices our
hotels our holders our lives what do you
have to say about this with scotty
pippen look scotty
let's take a lesson here bro
back up know your role do you understand
that he is now one of the greatest duos
of all time not because he he was a top
50 player
mj's the goat
the goat i don't think there's any
question of that now he feels slighted
he's coming back he feels fiscally
slighted
scotty i know he's dealing with a lot
with his wife larsa he feels like he's
you were you were looking to maybe buy
in his house at one point we looked at
his house okay that's actually a nice
house the basketball court on the right
side yeah
look
if i'm scotty
just stay in your lane bro you don't
want to make waves with mj this is not
the direction you want to go with the
the legacy of your career now he's
fighting with isaiah thomas you see what
isaiah thomas had to say about scotty
because scotty was talking trash about
isaiah about not making the dream team
isaiah says look i'll take it from mj
i'll take it from
you know hakeem or you know the greatest
of all time scotty know your role bro
yeah and this is just basically
overstepping you know you know what i'd
want to hear here's what i want to hear
if anybody has this and then we'll go to
the rest of them does anybody have an
argument to say that scotty's got a
point does anybody have an argument for
scotland i want to hear a little bit
i'm curious i have a unique perspective
because i was there for every day of the
last dance for those three literally i
was there every day i was in the middle
of everything you watched every game
yeah i was at every practice i was in
the i worked at nbc as the sports anchor
from 1995 to 1998. well people don't
know today was the guy with the white
goofy afro
he doesn't want to tell who he really is
tom tell us every single second of the
last dance rodman's parties we hosted a
show with dennis rodman every sunday
night we could do a whole show on me
just giving you rodman stories now
scotty's brand is exactly like it was
back then it's bitterness and it all
stems from money right it's all about
money with scottie pippen he knows he
got screwed over as a player he knows
how great of a player he was everybody
knows how great he was eight years on
that first concert seven years eighteen
million dollars time out though he
didn't get screwed he signed a badge
well yes he did and he knows it but
here's the other thing with scotty
here's the other problem with him
he hasn't evolved into a second act
right so everybody else is an analyst is
an executive is a is just a personality
an owner of a team a coach steve kerr
everybody is somebody he's still sitting
in that rocking chair whining about the
old days and he's bitter the wife has
something to do with it remember back in
the day his nickname was no pippins
no tipping pippin there was always
something about him he always had a chip
on his shoulder that helped him become a
great player no tip and pippin meaning
he never too he never tipped the
reputation in chicago michael also had
that reputation for not tipping no
no i don't think michael had that
michael was generous you know the
barclay interview with him and uh uh
oprah winfrey where barclay's like how
cheap michael is you don't remember that
like that okay but i think what he was
talking about is not paying back
gambling debts or something you know or
maybe not paying for a meal but scotty
had that reputation so look he is he's
not going to change because nothing from
his past is going to change he's not all
of a sudden going to make more money he
should he he controlled his own destiny
even with the last dance
that show would not have been the same
without him he should have said i want
something for participating and i
guarantee you one last thing this story
says michael jordan made 10 million for
the last dance he would make way more
than that all right with the success of
the last dance michael did not leave a
double 10 million to michael first of
all right and he's got he just salty at
this point
i think that's what he's just seen in
the documentary he's bitter and it's all
about money and you can kind of
understand that because you realize guys
right now make 18 million dollars a
month well my first story in the last
dance was the episode where basically he
refused to go into the game he wanted
the show
tony hit the shot the game winner and
and that's pippin's legacy as great of a
player as he was you can call him one of
the best duos the the the robin uh mj's
batman he's still the guy
that was too salty to go into the game
let me ask you let me ask you a question
let me ask you a question here's a
question for you i dropped that thing if
you don't mind picking it up here's a
question for you question for you is the
final one okay how many people knew uh
that michael and scotty won six
championships together how many people
people okay great fine just follow me
with you okay how many people knew steve
kerr and john paxton hit some of the
last you know three pointers or the
shots that they needed
everyone okay
how many millennials gen z's knew
the coach story with pippin who didn't
want to go in zero that's the point and
i think that if
i think if they would have left that
story out this would have never happened
but it needed to be in there i think if
they left that story out scotty's not
like this this is the thing with scotty
though he's not necessarily wrong uh
luke longley came out and did a whole
thing about the last dance and how much
they left out and how it was all about
glorifying jordan nobody cared because
he's luke longley and horace grant was
also a guy that was like what was i an
afterthought i was i was one of the best
players in the nba on the first on the
first three i left for a max contract so
horus grant to me they made him like a
clown like somehow you know robin was
one of my favorite players of all time i
have his jersey make fun of me from
wearing it around i love dennis rodman
but they acted like rodman came in and
like saved the franchise horace grant
was an amazing player so there there was
a narrative being formed around the fact
that like you know this thing was
falling apart and they had to get the
right pieces and it was jordan as a
leader i'll go get rodman from vegas and
stuff luke longley said the reason robin
was in vegas is he was sick of jordan
[ __ ] so that's why he's like screw this
how many titles do those guys win
without michael it's so easy to [ __ ]
about michael jordan don't get me wrong
but scottie pippen is getting the this
is the sign i want i want to hear this
because if the argument is so one-sided
with logic but i want to hear this side
to kind of hear it to you know listen to
luke lonely look like i saw what the
problem is but here's the thing okay so
here's the thing let's just say say luke
longley goes and does a documentary
let's go do a documentary look longer
how many people watching a lot in
australia okay say
say scotty goes as a documentary how
many people watch it
that's the thing he's going to make a
lot of money off of this so you know i'd
watch it would you watch horoscope i
watch it for a spin
oh by the way i would watch scottie
pippen's documentary but am i gonna
spend five weeks of every sunday night
from eight to ten at my house sitting in
the theater room watching it together
texting everybody saying did you see
what just happened now something that
you always talk about pat is
how many people
not going to be a five weeks or two
episodes something that you talk about
is that
mj has reached saints status
you can't because not he's not even
close how often do you say that when you
reach saint status like rogan has
reached status yeah dave chappelle has
reached out you can talk all the trash
you want about these people the thing is
you're not canceling you're not no one's
gonna lose you know lower them on the
totem pole but the thing is it's not
even so much that that he can't that you
can't say anything about jordan jordan
played when he was sick jordan played
after his dad was killed scotty
walked like bro we didn't for we don't
forget yeah then you walked away from
your team like we don't forget that like
you don't go in there crying because at
the end can you imagine had he not done
that how many endorsements he would have
got michael jordan is worth 1.5 million
dollars and it's not from the nba and
scotty was missing the big picture and
he's still doing it now sure because not
even that he did not negotiate in the
last to make any money ricky right but
he's always been horrible negotiation
without jordan
what did jordan win without scotty okay
so let's go there let's go there let's
actually go that's a good conversation
let's go there would jordan have one
without scotty he won when scotty had
walked out eventually he found a way to
pivot because that's michael jordan by
the way pivotal he's got a point couple
games game seven scotty was like i have
anxiety i have this i have that so but
the question is this let's say let's say
scotty that one season that he sits out
let's say kraus let's say those guys
trade them let's say they do
does jordan eventually win without
scouting
he never did how would we know i'll say
i'll say he wins at least one without
it's not about one guys it's not even a
question it's not even a question i say
jordan without scottie wins another
three or four i'm not saying six yeah
but i'm saying three or four okay let's
let's face it if if phil
if shaq and kobe could have gotten along
and phil could have made it work and
carmelo never came to the lakers
peyton never came to the lakers those
guys never came to the lakers they kept
the squad with the two main guys with a
couple role plays around them rodman
type of players defensive type of
players if they kept it that way how
many championships would have the lakers
won
unlimited
quite a few of them right now we
obviously don't know the answer to the
question but here's the part this is
this is the angle i take so gerard think
about when you and i are speaking
off-camera okay and we talk about
branding vision story future right what
do you want to be that one conversation
we had two and a half years ago in uh
the conference room where we're writing
all this stuff out on the board you know
what i'm talking about right sounds good
who is that for scotty who's sitting
there with scotty a good publicist
saying hey scotty i just want to have a
conversation with you buddy the route
you're going you're going to be the
better player that is not going to build
a brand i'm just letting you you can do
this but i'm just telling you let's
rebrand skies let's have a different at
this conversation with a couple other
guys in the last few months the market
thinks you're a dick this is not a good
look for you if you want the market to
change you got to change your approach
you can't be pointing fingers at
everybody all the time scotty went that
route scotty could have taken her out
and said
my sis my
argument would have been scotty the more
you edify
jordan the more the market's going to
say you're not a top 50 you're a top 25
the less the more you undermine jordan
the more you're top 100 because a big
part of that attitude is unattractive
it's just unattractive yeah being
gracious as you age is a bad bad look to
your point i would find out exactly who
did mike tyson's rebrand and i would pay
them everything marijuana mike tyson
went from you know having a tattoo and
threatening reporters on on air to
having a child's cartoon on adult swim
and you know being like a you know
america's crazy what what tyson has been
able to do is take a look at his past
indiscretions and all the mistakes he
made embrace them face the truth and say
and own up to it and say look i [ __ ] i
don't even know that guy anymore the
stories he says on podcast i know you've
interviewed him you've had moments with
him yeah he's so real at this point and
so inspiring that you can't help to to
love the guy who was probably he was the
baddest man on the planet
scotty needs to take a lesson for
michael yeah but it's got to be sincere
because that's the thing about tyson
it's legit he has that inside here but i
don't think scotty has it he's too
bitter he has to number one overcome
that bitterness for anything to change
i think that's what that's saying though
somebody has to tell him
somebody's got to grab him in the room
somebody has to be there
because because the way it's going right
now it's going to get worse it's not
going to get better right nobody is
turned on by a bitter guy nobody is no
one's turned on by that by the way even
look at barclay look at barclay's resume
actually look at his resume
never won a championship
never want to change he is loved he
never and he calls out everybody and he
says his own [ __ ] he never ever won a
championship probably one of the most
loved beloved guys ever he'll never be
in the category of a champion right now
the most teflon person in america can
get away with saying anything
okay but by the way think about
analytics by the way when when when
scotty talks and he gives us an
analytical side when i don't know which
one it is tnt or not tnt
he's on one of them when he doesn't i
sit there i'm like damn i didn't even
see that perspective and i'm not in the
world i felt like i went in the world so
scotty could be one of those guys right
the media and fans are not turned on by
bitterness
one more point about that era of the
bulls and i think this is part of the
problem for scotty
there will never be anything like those
bulls ever there was never anything like
it you know with no social media and
they'll never be anything like it again
with michael i think scotty got caught
between thinking am i an icon or do i
have to get another job and i thought he
was living off the fumes of the bull's
aura for so long and he didn't know how
to monetize that so then he was stuck in
this little gray area and it stuck with
him for 23 years you know i was trying
to say that scottie pippen can't afford
gucci flip-flops i think
is what the bitterness is coming from
you know the fan base they love humility
and champions with humility become
legacy and i'm gonna go to baseball for
the side of the table um because there's
something i've always always admired and
it's 1988 world series everybody talks
about the gibson home run but who
carried the team oral horserizer he won
the cy young that year he broke down
dodgedale's scoreless innings record at
59. pitched a shutout in game four and
pitched a shutout in game four shut down
shut the series off and all he has is
praise and admiration for kurt gibson
and that's how i got my ring and in
dodger land and he's a commentator at
the dodgers he his status is elevating
he didn't have a long enough career to
have hall of fame consideration but his
status is elevating because he's giving
praise to gibson he's giving praise to
lasorda and everybody looks at it you
know what he could say something
attractive he could he could be pissed
off and going down it i won the cy young
i broke
drysdale's record it was a 97 pitch
complete game that he threw in the world
series think about that by today's
standards 97 pitch complete game he
could be going down that and says damn
it why didn't i get the love
in a weird way this is this brings it
all back to like donald trump for me
it's like what made trump amazing he
edified it's great to be an american you
should be great i love being a part of
this we're winners let's get in together
and then he was bitter anybody says
anything bad about him i can see why
your husband left you you're ugly like
it's like he couldn't stop it's like you
can't just be like maybe scotty feels
this way pen pen be like look man you
know what i don't know if the last dance
really told the whole story there's some
things you didn't learn i'm gonna put it
in my doc love michael love the things
that we did together but there's another
side big picture rather than like going
for ted
instead of you know trying to win the
battle you know look at the war try to
win the war right now he's going after
yeah i didn't get this i didn't get this
if he looks at the big picture totally
and if someone sat him down in the room
and said look think about your legacy
think about what you want to be known as
not trying to win this little tip
that's the key though i really think and
you hit the nail on the head as you age
like he's an icon he's this it's the
people like that you you start listening
to right it's the person that has to be
all the time who can sit scottie pippen
down that he'll actually listen to him
be like scotty bro cut the [ __ ] you know
what it is somebody has to say the
following somebody has to say look like
even with
kids or people you talk to you know hey
the other day uh dylan's like hey daddy
am i better than sam in jet ski no
you're not
you're not he's way better than you and
jet ski i said well you're better than
when i was eight years old on jet ski
because i've never freaking been on jet
ski until i was my third you know i said
you're better than me when i was eight
years old it's like okay i'm better than
you like eight years old right it's
somebody has to say i don't know bro hey
scotty there's no just kissing iran
so anyway so somebody has to tell scotty
behind closed doors scotty i love you
you're amazing you and michael i'm just
telling you stop acting like you're
better than michael and fyi every time
you edify lebron to say he's better than
michael everybody knows what you're
doing everyone knows that's coming from
an insecure place stop it just like when
isaiah says lebron's better than michael
isaiah we all know you're pissed that
you didn't make it on the dream team
everyone knows michael's better than
lebron everyone knows michael's better
than scottie what are you doing it's not
even like that argument so scotty could
have taken a different route listen 40
laws of power rule number one you know
what rule number one is never outshine
the master don't replace the boss for
the face of the team replace the boss
for master replace the boss for whatever
the mvp is you don't outshine jordan if
he doesn't outshine jordan he's going to
get a million and one other
opportunities
one last thing
psychology
pat i mean the fact that he doesn't have
a supportive wife now i don't know
anything about their marriage for real
but i do know she's chasing headlines
and she's not probably sitting there
telling scotty how great he is and he's
been humiliated by her by some of her
actions so that doesn't help that
doesn't help matters either true i don't
yeah but by the way i mean that's that's
who you marry but at the same time
he's not the first person that had
accumulating stories with wives on the
personal life you still gotta you know
people can have a choice on what they're
gonna do that's what i want to say
before we move on let me let me just
remind everybody that's listening to
this
20 super chat gets you in the giveaways
we have a playstation 5 we're going to
be giving away iphone signed books and a
couple other surprises we get to ten
thousand people live by the third hour
the last super chat will give ten
thousand dollars away but you gotta
share this with others to get to ten
thousand live we'll give a ten thousand
dollar super chat away we got a surprise
guest that's gonna be coming here but go
ahead you were gonna say you're fine i
know we're just piling on scotty we're
sitting on scotty that
the wife thing is true she's definitely
embarrassing him and going after
headlines she's dating a guy malik
beasley in minnesota you know 20 years
her senior he did lose his son scottie
pippen jr over the last six months
and yeah that's noticeable that's sad
you know so he's been going through some
stuff he's probably dealing with major
mental issues anxiety
depression he's lashing out
someone does need to sit him down but he
is going through it bro and i hope he
gets we love scott he loves you totally
now great point on what you just said
right there that's why adam what i go
back to is sometimes we have a
conversation and it's a private
conversation that's just between you and
i it's not the world's issues it's you
and i talking about it right
those people that are around you that
are not afraid to tell you listen dude
chill out a little bit kick back a
little bit
if you eliminate those people out of
your life
i'm sorry you're going to have more
situations like this scotty needs to
bring some of those people in his life
to say
you know chill out a little bit
i think we're rooting for scotty we are
like we are like he's a beloved nba
superstar we've got a special guest here
uh a special gift from chica lopez who
just gave 20 and he's listening to this
chico this is a shout out for you we got
kobe in the house what's up little kid
kobe
don't eat him gerard we finally agreed
on the name
oh my gosh it's mine yeah we just got it
last week oh he's so cute oh dude look
at this guy look at this guy you can put
him on the table here let him kick back
a little let's see what he does maybe he
just joins us don't pull a biden don't
be my boy
no seriously
look at that
american pit bull
the other two dogs are not big fans can
we put his face up on the camera so
people can see it's so bad for jimbo and
coach right they're not a fan man
he bites them he wrestles them and they
run away they're not
can you put him on the camera tom let's
let's uh there you go
oh look at that thing
huh
i don't think so i don't know yet but uh
we're in love with this guy man he came
in another one of those things man first
night i'm having a conversation with
mario at midnight i'm like mario i think
i'm going to give the dog to eric
and mario says pat just sleep on it like
here we go i'm going to sleep on it for
16 years that's what's going to happen
but
he's with us he's kicking it he's having
a blast so uh pat when i started kicking
it with you you had three kids and two
dogs now you got four kids three dogs uh
an even bigger house you got your dad
living with you you know
yeah you just you said i'm here let me
pile it on are you are you suggesting to
add cats to that or what's like is there
like a maybe you want to have a cat or
something what do you what are you
trying to do
diversify yeah diversify how about we do
another giveaway uh samville are you
ready because people are throwing the
20s in there even gerard michaels
threw twenty dollars and then he wants
to win that you can't win he wins it
it'll be
collapsible
it's rigged
okay uh uh is this fake jarred michaels
uh is this like somebody out there being
fake drug martial
okay kai can you do this here's what i'm
thinking but what do we do to make next
giveaway do we do an iphone do we do a
nice sick coffee machine what do we do
do we do the iphone let's do an iphone
we'll do an iphone that's the 13. that's
the latest one okay so let's see here's
the iphone time if you want to grab it
so the next thing we're giving away is
the iphone 13
uh uh uh iphone 13 samuel if you're
ready
let's do the next one and if we crack
tenth out we're gonna apparently steve
wozniak not a fan of this gosh look at
all those names
look at all those names the next one is
some bill that's a lot
all right here we go this next one is
for brand spanking new iphone anna too
uh here we go signed copy and oh amazing
let's see what comes up
let's
shout out to fran drescher by the way
one of the most underrated hotties of
the 90s that shoes they say my mom
looked at the nanny what yeah you should
picture my mom when she was younger
away from your mom bro
put it on there recently
okay
gerard julie looks like you're gonna
need a babysitter buddy a nanny jose
jose carrot area well shout out to mom
okay shout out to jose all right let's
keep going let's keep going next story
next story next story next story let's
talk about uh pirate pilot under
investigation for saying let's go
brandon morale morale thank you for the
text to clarify what let's go brandon
means i appreciate them a lot moreover
texts me the meaning of that's good i
would think that she understands your
sarcasm at this point i think i think
she is also being sarcastic but she she
and shout out to loser alexander for the
number one song in america despite being
uh being banned off all the youtube
channels let's go bro
under
during announcements southwest airlines
says abc 13 houston story a southwest
airline pilot under investigation after
you allegedly used the phrase used as a
way of swearing at president joe biden
the incident happened friday on a flight
out of houston the pilot was finishing
his announcement when he used the phrase
let's go brandon an associate press
reporter on the flight said there were
audible gasps from passengers after the
pilot ended the announcement in a
statement southwest airlines said it is
conducting an internal investigation
into the reported why event while
continuing to remind all employees that
public expression of personal opinions
while on duty is unacceptable okay
but you couldn't work
okay they literally kicked people off
they had trump hats but it's
unacceptable that's [ __ ] let's go to
adam first adam
what's your thoughts with this story
totally offended well i look this is
cute please appreciate adam's emotions
i know a lot of people famous people who
would just straight up saying
f trump yeah like full-on
like it wasn't they weren't hiding it
there was no code word there wasn't some
cute little let's go brandon thing going
on they were coming out and just saying
[ __ ] trump straight up and you know this
is a cute little quirky way of saying
[ __ ] biden okay i get it
um
i hope we get to a point where
americans aren't basically saying fu to
the president whether that's trump or
that's biden and this is why well i mean
i think we're kind of there i think i
would hope the next president who i do
not hope is trump or biden i hope it has
a different name than those two old
bastards
i would hope that a new president
doesn't get hated on this much i hope
that our next president has a 60
approval rating and then we can have a
president that we can at least stomach
whether on the left or on the right so
for now you know if you want to do the
let's go brandon thing and you think
that's funny you think that's cute and
think that the song is actually good god
bless you but i hope that the next
president
i'm going to wear my brandon shirt on my
next on the next podcast
by the way like i'm dead serious already
bought it
i already i'm going to wear it every
time i get in there you know i got
inspired yesterday i jumped on the plane
to come here and uh uh uh older man
probably about 60 65 years old had a
let's go brandon a hashtag fjab on his
shirt i was so inspired on the spot as
soon as i sat down i went on amazon and
bought three shirts cool story rick
that's uh that's right that's one of
them
yeah so i mean there's three things
really when i come to that all right
like would it be great to have a
president that we all like yes it would
be awesome we need it we haven't had one
in really 20 years almost right we can
have somebody that can bring us together
but there is nothing more american than
being able to go double barrels up at
the king we throw we've been throwing
tea in the harbor from the very first
day so the fact that we can do that
while china makes it illegal to make fun
of their heroes i love the fact of that
but it's also the let's go brandon isn't
about joe biden this is what the people
on the left especially in the
twitterverse are missing it's about the
gaslighting it's about the lying it's
it's making fun of them for being like
really really they say they're saying
let's go brandon because for people that
don't know out there and know pat does
know this comes from a nascar driver won
his very first race yeah all right and
named brandon
correct and the the crowd was audibly
chanting [ __ ] joe biden yeah and the nbc
reporter go listen to the crowd listen
to them they're chatting let's go
brandon and him at the podium goes
uh i don't think so sure that's what
you're chanting so it's not about joe
biden it's about them constantly lying
and constantly trying to augment what
you're saying but it was one lady that
maybe didn't know that
where did the left lose their sense of
humor like the audible they were audible
gasps about how dare they make fun of
our president like how can you not laugh
at yourself you got caught with your
pants down laugh at yourself it's the
same thing with them protesting dave
chappelle like you said before like wow
we don't like jokes in this country
like dude the left has completely lost
their freaking sense of humor well when
you
and i'm hoping joe manchin who has held
his ground over the last two weeks
now after what happened what do you mean
maybe five percent i didn't say five
percent no you said maybe five percent
no no i said i'm not making fun of him
for saying maybe five percent oh it's
much much
more than that much so hang on cat man
you're like
you guys have no idea what it's like to
get made fun of by a full-on dweeb it's
like
it's like okay i'm getting tried right
now i love you but i just got tried by a
professional nerd
okay this is where we're at right now
that's okay go ahead you know
no no no i mean you're look look how
you're trying to distance from it i'm
not just doing anything i said that
trump like people are saying stop
yelling you're going to yell over me
you know you win the argument with a
liberal in the yelling and name calling
starts for reference it takes 16 seconds
so my point
so
my point was like oh you're trying to
say oh five percent of the democratic
party you're trying to distance yourself
and call them sort of a awoke little
little bit there right so you don't even
want to be around you know the the the
truth of the thing it's more than five
percent dude it's more than five it's a
very vocal very significant part is that
the far left that you're trying to say
oh it's just this little five percent so
how far how what percentage is the far
left
literally joe manchin you're a numbers
guy what's the percentage that is the
only guy quote unquote far left
kai are you typing or are you waiting
for what percentage is far left
you know there's i'd like to you're
sitting there
what's the matter you may want to put
that fingers to use
what's the number
who's what percentage of this country
would be considered far less hold
fortune.com says the far right
represents only six percent of u.s
citizens
that's far right i agree okay far right
is six percent so to adam's argument
if far left is five six percent i think
that sounds about right on far left five
six percent of democrats forty two
percent which means it's really twelve
percent of america okay so so you
understand hold on hold on yeah we need
to define what that is now because what
far left is today
and what far left was ten years ago are
not even in the same ballpark what we
would consider far left 10 years ago
that's correct is pretty normal almost
left of center today
so i mean the the country has sprinted
so far left so fast and we've had this
conversation so i mean you know we need
to better def first of all i hate the
concept of left and right it's such an
antiquated concept anyway but the the
country that your favorite word the
zeitgeist has moved so far left so quick
that anybody that was in that center as
the culture shifted now if you were
center 10 years ago you're considered
far right today can you imagine what jfk
would be today do you imagine john f
kennedy a democrat jfk would be on that
on a republican they would say that he
is a far right extremist he'd be like
joe manchin he would not be
ask not what your country could do for
you that's what you could do for your
country you're taking one phrase and
making it it was a big phrase okay i'm
saying
but he would be what where joe manchin
is so soviet so let me ask you a
question since you made that point so
what do you think is far left today
what percentage do you think it's let's
define far left far left is what is aoc
far left yes it's elizabeth warren yes
is joe biden far left no no no but it's
possible yeah but here's
the part around him
yes obama's far left hey here's the
problem the media's far left so you got
the biggest microphone out there
healthcare amplifying everything thank
you i don't consider obama far left well
you got to understand this policy i
think what i think obama especially
these days is
i don't think he's center left i think
he's left
to me a far left to me what are we going
to say further left and far left it's
far left to me is aoc elizabeth warren
bernie sanders omar omar those guys
look who he campaigns for he's going to
be behind everyone for real do you think
cuomo was far left or less no i think
he's left yeah mansion is he is he far
left left or center left center
center okay so what okay so now let me
ask you a question let's go far right is
it trump far right
is he far right he said he's rhetoric
or his power i don't think i think he's
left right center up down i think he has
no
rhyme or reason i
just to bring some reason to this
conversation the right likes to think
there are people that are far right
they're only right and the left things
the people that are far left or only
left so there's there's a trend that we
have to understand we have to be aware
of this selective hearing or selective
whatever you want to call the biases
yeah that we're going through it all i'm
saying today is i don't think the far
left is as big as you think it is fyi
let me explain what i mean by this let
me let me let me give my argument i want
to hear back because this is a world you
were part of i think
i think uh
we're doing an art we're doing a episode
on cancer culture right and we pull up
all the people that have said stuff
about cancer culture you should hear
what obama said about cancer culture you
should hear what sharon stone said about
cancer culture you should hear about
what the girl from fifty shades of grey
what is the name dakota something
johnson what is her name dakota johnson
john johnson what's she said about the
uh uh cancer culture what is bill
marshall you should hear what alec
baldwin said about cancer culture so so
what is starting to happen today is the
following i tweeted something out the
other day i said i said logic and common
sense is making a comeback is what i
tweeted out a guy sent a picture saying
the rapper logic and comment have been
around for a while
which i thought it was hilarious but i
said logic and common sense are making a
comeback people are starting to sit
there and say
yeah i don't know bro i mean i'm a
democrat but i i i don't know i don't
know if i'm cool going to that point
right there i'm not right i think
there's a lot of people today like a
bill maher like a russell brand like
russell branded a video diary on let's
go brandon yeah i mean are you kidding
me russell brandt did a video on let's
go where do you think he is politically
i think he's center left i think he's a
left guy let's go where do you think
dave is nothing to do with joe biden
what do you think dave chappelle is i
think i think that i think that dave
chappelle is probably center left i
think david chappelle is center left
today and what you're seeing is is
backlash from people who are i would
consider myself a moderate like i'm a
pretty like i get it i can go left today
today i'm sorry but a year and a half
ago okay but the point because a lot of
that is being gaslighted by trump's
rhetoric sure and people saying i can't
go for that 80 million people whether
you believe it or not said whatever that
is i'm out and they use this stopgap
president joe biden joe biden will go
down historically as the greatest
motivational speaker maybe the record
but the point is you have people that
you're self-proclaiming as center left
whether it's russell brand whether it's
dave chappelle whether it's bill maher
who is saying that over there to the far
left we ain't with that and that's what
we need and that's what people on the
right need to do to the far right but
let me ask you this crazy question just
for you i'm not asking anybody else i'm
just asking you here just for you you
ready here's a question for you okay
do you think there is more far right
today or do you think there's more far
left today i think there is more far
left today okay perfect i agree i think
i think that's the argument i think
there is a bigger far left today than
far right i think far left is probably
twice as many as far right because
far-right argument is what what is a
far-right argument you you if you think
about it you look at what the proud boys
or what queued whatever
you said it's six percent of the country
yeah and by the way maybe that's
10 on the you know you know the guy that
you know the guy that did the
documentary on q and on i don't know
what the guy's david what's the guy's
name that did the documentary on
queueing on colin hill what's his name
colin holbeck
we interviewed him the other day like
last week yeah last week yeah and so the
whole six uh episode i think it's six
five or six episodes about q and on and
he finally ended up finding out who was
behind q and on these two guys watkins
or ron watkins and the father and son
and how they were doing it an accident
he says yeah we're behind you and i was
like wait so it's not a military guy so
it's not this you got to also realize
that today there's so many ways to troll
yourself into becoming a celebrity
there's so many ways to manipulate and
spin and confuse the [ __ ] out of
everybody gas lining is a skill set
today trolling is a skill set today and
some of the best trolls are nerds
sitting behind a computer that are 19
years old saying i'm gonna act like i'm
a big freaking military guy that thinks
this this is happening some of those
guys are both at fault by the way to
figure out a way to to divide so the far
right guys are fake people most of them
are fake people that are just trying to
get some attention they're playing games
yeah they're struggling yeah but
something that
needs to be said is that
the far left maybe their universal
health care or tax the rich or even
commies as gerard likes to call them
maybe they are the people on the far
right literally think democrats are
eating babies
like let's not dismiss that it's not the
same argument i've not heard that one
you've never that's
are you suggesting your adrenal chrome
doesn't exist
i'm saying that you probably think all
democrats are drinking adrenochrome
where it's like
0.0001 of somebody that might have done
it but there's okay no no you're this
see this is the beauty of what they've
done with the with the cue stuff right
you take something that's nuts you take
something that's insane and you put it
in the same list of things that are
actually really plausible right like
what was on john d podesta's uh laptop
absolutely needed to be investigated
this idea that pizzagate is this
nonsensical thing you watch you you go
down the pizzagate rabbit hole and i'm
not saying it's 100 true i'm not making
allegations but i'm saying
there's enough to
cause there's cause for investigation
here there's some really really atypical
[ __ ] that went down the stuff that was
on that was on uh anthony weiner's
laptop that we never found out about
it was gross enough that people in the
new york city police department walked
outside and threw up
they saw what was on it they threw up
and anthony weiner has clearly been held
accountable for that has he really do
you know what's on there do you have any
i don't know yeah it's not like i'm
hanging out with anthony weiner and know
what's on his laptop
the point i'm trying to make is that
it's a rough name it's a rough name to
hang out with tony wiens yeah but the
point i'm trying to make is that that
it's really easy to take something that
that might be true and instead of
debunking it surround it with bs like
there's lizards under the there's losers
under antarctica and it's like okay well
anything these people believe is
nonsense they did this with the on a
much smaller scale they did this with
jose canseco when jose canseco came out
and said
everybody in the major leagues is on
steroids the first thing they turn
around said this guy's a jerk this guy's
an [ __ ] he doesn't know anything
about anything and they try to discredit
him through saying all the dumb stuff
that he did and it turned out he was 100
right about everything so listen i'm not
saying democrats are not eating babies
or anything like that no but the fact is
that there is human trafficking that's
100 true we saw that video at the border
which is insane there's an entire uh uh
i mean the wayfarer thing went away like
this and they were that was insane that
there was ten thousand dollar dressers
and pillows that were named the same
names of children that had gone missing
so i mean
this the idea that you could just take
this and throw it away as some grand
conspiracy is exactly what they hope and
you do and it's it's nonsense that some
of these things absolutely need to be
very deep what percentage of people
or democrats if you want to call it are
actually
involved in this
salacious stuff i don't think it's
democrats less than 0.01 like yeah but
that's what makes it okay that's my
point that's what makes the elites
elites that's like saying what
percentage of people have access to
nuclear technology it doesn't mean that
because it's a small percentage it's not
dangerous i agree with you i actually
agree with you you make a great point
here but the point is it's such a small
fraction of people that
to be labeled yeah but democrats are all
social wait a minute or democrats are
all eating babies no no no
but the rebuttal to that would be it's
the people in power bingo who are doing
that that's the difference and they're
implementing policies yeah so that's the
difference during all this stuff that
catapulted to the forefront of the news
trump was in power
q and b was he really though was he
really though was he not the president
so so go ahead process that one right
there you're saying trump was in power
of what
what he was the president of the country
what what can the president actually
investigate
what can he actually go investigate
what happened with all these laptops
what could he actually do could he
actually say go invest you really think
a president can call the fbi and say go
investigate biden's laptop something
just happened right now to the audience
whatever you touch
okay okay good so so no no but the point
is here
even though you're president you ain't
running the fbi what was the fbi doing
fbi was uh you know the donors to
hillary's camp and uh cuomo so
so not cuomo what's his name uh uh comey
so you know it's not president is not in
charge buddy we learned that very very
quickly do you think it was donald trump
junior's laptop they wanted they wanted
uh
it would have been all over the news
uh with that anyways okay so so far
we've done how many giveaways we've done
three giveaways okay twenty dollars gets
you into a super chat we've given away
an iphone 32 we've done two we've given
away an iphone 13 we've given away monte
cristo cigars let's think about guys why
don't you put down here what you want to
be the giveaway i did say this at the
tenth thousand
dollar ten thousand uh live watching us
we'll do ten thousand dollar giveaway
today if we hit that number of ten
thousand can i make one point about
southwest pilot he should be fired i i
you know as funny as people think that
is that right that is so uh the wrong
place to be doing it and inappropriate
and the last thing you want is friction
on a plane at 35 000 feet and you know
only on southwest could something like
that happen because they all think
they're comedians right with their
announcements or anything but i'm
appalled by that i i just think it was a
totally inappropriate and unprofessional
thing for him to do so do you think
teachers should be fired when they bring
their politics into the classroom yes um
every teacher look it's different
because they're not in an enclosed tube
35 000 feet above the air where people
what are they going to do bro like
usually have some decorum and some
standards no i understand but and i'm
with you and i'm i'm a let's go brandon
fan all the way right a million times
over but uh but
yeah
because they were kicking but at the
same time though it never got
investigated when many american airlines
united delta um uh what do they call the
the the ladies that help you and the
final attendance were literally kicking
people off a place for having trump hats
so why was there no investigation there
well there should be that as well all
politics should be out of the air but i
i i we're going way too deep into this
every time somebody says something i
don't like we should fire him we should
fire everybody
and by the way it works the same way if
someone if the pilot said f trump
as someone who doesn't supports trump
that guy should be in trouble too
you fly the plane bro this isn't the
time to start getting on your soapbox
talking polishes
fly yeah if you're the plane yes yeah
shut up and fly the plane yeah you're
not here to give a speech whether you
support trump let's go brandon this
ain't we ain't here for you maybe we
didn't sign up for a speech maybe
if this is the part that i'm trying to
hear both of you guys out should he be
fired should he not be fired do i like
that comment being made in a situation
like that probably not because i look at
it as a even by the way lebron said shut
up chump he didn't decide to come to the
white house anyways when he was talking
about stuff i don't like that stuff i at
all don't like that stuff because
what you're what you don't realize is
you're allowing the enemy to see how
divided the country i'm not a fan of
that however
the problem would have been if this
pilot like who was that uh david who was
the guy we interviewed who was space for
commander space for commander matthew
lot
matthew lomar who got fired yes because
of what he said on his own platform in
an article about the fact that military
was teaching marxism principles etc etc
they fired him from being a space for
commander i think that shouldn't have
happened this was a factual it was but
it's not about the factual stem so if
this pilot
southwest airlines pilot goes on
instagram and he says hey have a great
weekend everybody and by the way let's
go brandon
he says that fine i understand but on a
flight on
i don't know i just i'm trying to really
process it i don't know if i want my kid
to hey
that was so funny dylan yeah no dylan
that's not funny you don't do that kind
of stuff when you're leading because
you're not a leader that's not a leader
you want to do it on instagram you want
to share your opinions listen go for it
hey have a great weekend let's go
brandon go you know alabama whatever
yeah so time and place yeah there's a
time and place for this guy's like
there's enough going on in the in the
air right now that we don't need to get
politicize a flight that's that's a
great point right now in the air you
have all this tension with passengers
because you know you have the strained
announcement that comes from the purser
up there in first class and by the way
we have to enforce the federal mandate
about wearing a mask in the air unless
you're eating or drinking you can lower
it briefly that is the standard of the
air and we are enforcing that and you
notice how they always kind of put the
federal government there so there's a
lot of tension that's happening up there
there's a lot of tensions in there and
we don't need more tension kind of
sparking people who are already you know
i don't want any additional tension
there i want to get on take my flight
and get where i'm going yeah i agree i
could i get something behind that i
don't i don't disagree with anything
anybody said i just don't like the idea
that everybody should always get fired
no i i i'm with you there i'm with you
there i think a fine it would be
appropriate some sort of some sort of
repercussion repercussion but we can't
just have
we can't have our pilots think about how
like we're in the we're floating in the
sky right now and our pilots are giving
political speeches or indoctrination
whether look whatever team you're on
just understand this the other half of
the country doesn't agree with you and
the other half of the country has a
different set of beliefs we're all
americans especially on the freaking
plane god forbid there was an issue on
the plane and the gas masks come down
you're not going to ask hey who'd you
vote for i think there's major issues i
really think you should be fired i mean
what if you just stop sticking to that
totally because you know not everybody
that says something you don't agree with
or gets political should be fired a
pilot should be what if you tick off or
some
trip a tripped-out dude in the back goes
nuts or a flight attendant i mean
there's repercussions from that there's
just there's no benefit of saying
something like that and they know they
shouldn't do it and there is a
difference between saying it like to a
passenger to a colleague and doing it on
the loudspeaker
for the entire plane to hear and by the
way i don't know what airlines you're on
those things that come down aren't gas
masks or oxygen masks oxygen mask there
we go that's a very interesting airline
i don't want to be on that one
in his defense he's not doing it for
political reasons he's doing it because
him and his fellow colleagues are about
to be fired for not being vaccinated
he's not doing it to be like i'm
republican he's doing he did it out of
solidarity for everybody in his company
that he's been working with who is about
to be let go because of these policies
so it had he might have even voted for
biden for all that we know we have no
idea what his politics were this was
about don't fire my friends and
colleagues because of their medical
decisions so he his stand wasn't to be
like i hope i piss off every democrat in
here let's let's move on fair fair i i
we've had plenty of back and forth on
this one uh i say we go into the next
story which is american shrinking
workforce a puzzle for economist page
two okay so this is an epoch time story
america's shrinking workforce a puzzle
for economist the u.s economy is
suffering from a labor shortage posing a
difficult puzzle for economists and
policy makers to solve americans are
quitting their current jobs at a record
pace the labor department showed data
that quits uh increased to 4.3 million
in august the highest on record dating
back to december 2000 a gallup survey
discovered that 48 of the working
population the united states is actively
looking for new job or watching for
opportunities the ongoing labor shortage
is the single most significant threat to
america's economic recovery according to
the u.s chamber of commerce the nation's
biggest business lobbying group congress
should drop the multi-millionaire dollar
tax and spend proposals that would
further undermine the economy and focus
on getting americans back to work and
helping employers feel open jobs the
business group said in a statement
yesterday i saw an article kai i send it
to you i don't know if you have it with
you or not yesterday there was this
article that mark cuban tweeted out do
you have that can you put that article
up i send it to you in a group text with
me you and um
and uh mario i'll text it to you right
now as well matter of fact i'm gonna
send it to your ipad
uh uh i'm sending it to you right now if
you see it
yeah the crypto story put that up there
for people to see very interesting what
mark cuban put up about crypto
very very interesting what mark cuban
put up on crypto if you can put that
story up kai
krypto is creating newfound wealth and
job freedom for many americans okay yeah
so so check this out by the way uh when
we when we bought the bitcoin how much
did we buy the bitcoin originally for
fifty thousand one point five bitcoin
fifty thousand
and we gave it to you when we gave it to
a week ago or two weeks ago two weeks
ago what price was when we gave you that
money cash 94 000. we gave you 94 000
dollars we transferred over to them so
the bitcoin was 62 300 at that day when
we gave it we bought it at 32 we gave it
to him at 62. so instead of giving ricky
only fifty thousand dollars in bitcoin
he got ninety five thousand dollars in
his account last we give you a bitcoin
and a half yes okay bitcoin in half okay
so now watch this watch this here
watch this year watch this article here
okay whether you invested in
cryptocurrency or understand what it is
there's no denying that over the last
year it has demonstrated staying power
in bitcoin for instance as of time of
writing is valued at 61 000 per bitcoin
skyrocketing nearly 50
while some preconception
cryptocurrencies invested uh invis in
young and uh uh tech-savvy individuals
possibly anti-establishment mindset the
bigger picture of kurt thomas a little
more noise okay so here's what it goes
to this is the next sentence that's the
key for instance while crypto wealth is
undoubtedly growing that doesn't
necessarily mean any significant portion
of people are quitting their jobs as a
result 11 of the general population
reports either having personally quit
their jobs or known someone who has as a
result of their crypto investments so
mark cuban is saying another reason why
people quit is because they made so much
money in crypto right now that they're
just kind of sitting there saying
i'm not i'm not a guy but he's saying
he's saying do the opposite this doesn't
mean you're wealthy officially it just
means one your investments did well you
should go back to your work and your job
anyways i'll pause your thoughts on the
shrinking workforce a puzzle for
economist time i'm going to come to you
first yeah what's going on right now is
you got to take a look at the service
economy who is streaming loudest about
labor shortage restaurants
retails stores that are opened again um
regardless whether it's a red or blue
state you can only have a hospitality
hospitality it's all there and those
were the people that were getting
assistance they were getting the checks
from the government for assistance and
they were a certain unemployment
assistance was coming from
uh their individual states and so what
it showed you when we only have you know
when when this all started we were at
very low unemployment right which means
we had a very low supply of workers you
screw with that supply even a little bit
it wreaks havoc and now
you what you see is the service economy
is looking for people i saw the dunkin
donuts and this was not a meme this was
really dunkin donuts hey please be
patient come on in you know we'll get to
you and if you don't like the service
maybe you'd like a job application their
point was we need somebody to serve you
the donut so that's number one and then
number two with the unemployment you
don't have to mess very much with your
labor bases and maybe it is a little bit
of crypto a little bit of an up market
and
i i think we don't appreciate just what
a wonderful engine the american economy
was and we have taken a little bit of
unemployment in there over um
covid impact and now coming back with
assistance programs you don't have to
take much off the top of labor to create
a massive shortage and and i think the
um
a difficult puzzle for economists and
policy makers maybe you guys need to get
out a little more maybe you're at home
meeting door door dash all you got to do
is walk down main street of any
mid-sized
uh
city and take a look there are active
now like little help wanted signs and
the others are on the windows and i'm
like why is there help one inside on the
window they can all the job things
monster.com and everything they're
online but that's what i'm saying i'm
seeing you you didn't need to mess very
much with the labor base in america to
pinch a whole lot of industries that
desperately need need workers yeah i'll
echo what he says then maybe a few other
things gallup poll i mean sometimes when
you're being polled do you actually give
an honest answer uh so i always put a
little margin in there for some
discrepancy with that um the empowerment
that employees have right now it's so
easy to quit a job
and they feel so empowered go on strike
someone else will hire you the
government will give you money yeah i
mean i i find it troubling to be honest
with you how powerful employees think
they are i think it's great you know if
you have it use it but whatnot but it's
just getting a little weird and a little
imbalanced another one of the factors is
baby boomers dying i mean there's a
there's a legitimacy to that more baby
boomers have died in the last two years
that we're working that's going to skew
this a little bit and the last thing is
automation you know there's a lot of
businesses and industries that are going
deep on automation so you combine all
those things that tom said some of these
factors these numbers and the pandemic
right and we got a problem well a lot of
people look we just got a letter
yesterday
two days ago
they're giving the dirt stimulus like we
don't mean erica we don't catch how to
cash out on them third stimulus oh do
here to apply
bro everybody's getting these letters
they're giving away
ricky got his stimulus last week
they're bitcoin done giving stimulus why
would i go back to work yeah it makes no
sense to go back to work so the the
shortage on top of you know tom
obviously is very wise when it comes
down to this but i'm i'm getting a
letter for a third time for a stimulus
check a third time and i just got it two
days ago why would i go back to work all
i gotta do is pay my bills for you know
like a lot of these guys and i even
asked people how did you do it they gave
me the stimulus i paid my rent for six
months i kept a little money and i'm
surviving off of that oh and then
they're not paying their rent by the way
some of them are not paying their rent
yeah because now you can so so they're
keeping they're they're sitting on this
money the majority of them
that is going to let them get through
for the next you know eight to ten
months stimulus is like coveted boosters
we're gonna have the third the fourth
the fifth it's not gonna stop we found
another mary's out there i think you
make a really good point ricky because
net one year who's freaking out right
now on terms of political strategy
democrats are freaking out there's a
whole thing going on there so if we
think these stimulus checks are going to
stop
as long as they control the three houses
you know the three branches
um
i i think we're missing something i
think we're gonna stimulus all the way
through the midterms because it's gonna
be like it's gonna be like candy to the
voters i don't know tom i have a very i
at this table i have a very minority
opinion on this i know already stimulus
is nothing new 40 acres and a mule is
nothing new manifest destiny is nothing
new there's always been an incentive the
government pays people to go do whatever
it wants to do right so if they want to
stimulate not the way it's happening
right now sure understood but nothing's
happening the way that it's ever
happened before technology is different
this is actually it's a great point
that's what i'm looking for just
remember 40 of the money that's ever
been printed in the united states as pat
has pointed out several times it's what
happened in the last 20 months yes i
understood completely but here's the
thing biggest training you are you you
brought up uh you brought up dunkin
donuts before right if i'm working at
dunkin donuts and it's 12.75
an hour all right and i'm looking at a
iced coffee being sold for 5.50 i'm
saying to myself an hour of my life is
only worth two freaking iced coffees no
it's the gig more than crypto which by
the way one of the first podcasts i did
crypto was tanking you were kind of
making fun of me for crypto you're like
you're the cell i was like absolutely
not i buy the dip and then like right so
i mean i'm all remember that but okay
i'm sorry i'm sure our guys pbd podcast
instagram can find it the uh but there's
crypto is the future especially when we
get into the middle of metaverse crypto
is the president it's not even the
future and it's more than crypto it's
the gig economy where the young
generation is not getting married
they're not having kids they're not
buying houses right you talked about
rent half these guys are it's okay like
remember back in the day chris farley
had that great uh that great segment if
you don't do this you'll be smoking the
reefer living in a vehicle
yeah living in a van
down by the river hashtag van lifestyle
is a whole thing people they they get
these vans and they deck them out and
it's called mini living and they do this
thing the young generation understands
that their time is worth something to
them and it's not 12.75 what the
businesses especially these massive
large chains have not figured out is how
to attract that employee and i think
yeah i don't think that money the
solution i don't think it's the money i
honestly think it's the hours i think
that the first person that goes i'm
gonna pay your rent and you're only
gonna have to work four hours a week for
those people that don't want to be
massive millionaires then the business
is not sustainable i think this is the
only route on what the
those companies are going to be doing
here's exactly what those companies are
going to be doing they're going to stop
trying to get those young guys to work
for them they're going to automate every
single thing and they're going to say no
problem buddy you don't want to work for
12.50 which is the minimum wage it's not
really that it doesn't take that much to
flip a burger but you don't want to be a
barista for 15 bucks an hour totally
fine we'll automate all of this
eventually it'll be automated
short term
short term the employers win long term
the employees win short term the
employer wins long term sure because the
employers are so if any time you're
looking for a solution here's how this
works you can sit there and say well you
know uh do it screw it i'm just gonna go
out there and do this you're right every
time i've done that as a human being i
made a short-term decision and it was
successful for a month three months six
months 12 months long term it was not
successful
these decisions what you're talking
about could be short-term success it's
going to be catastrophic long-term
because math the math doesn't make sense
now let me flip it on you
let me flip it on you i just think this
is they're making it they're making a
decision they're making a cultural
decision i get that and they're going to
pay price for it there's a price to be
paid for now let me flip it on you let
me flip it on you where i agree with you
uh where we can go into a meta
conversation as well uh i think
we're old
i think we're old officially we are old
let's face it everybody at this table is
officially old okay everybody if you're
and let me unpack what i mean by that
let me unpack what i mean by that
the younger generation is about to do a
clinic on us and it's going to happen
and people have to be ready for it
and you have to be so prepared for
what's about to happen okay the other
day i'm sitting there and i'm watching
my kid my oldest son
uh my youngest son you guys know what he
looks like he looks like he's you know
he's ready to go play today football all
this stuff i was with him this morning
just seeing this guy athletic wants to
be out there right my oldest son wants
to make video games my oldest son wants
to go out and play video games my oldest
son wants to sit there and he's great at
playing video games right and you know
these guys that are very good at playing
videos and it's a different kind of
wiring and i'm sitting as a parent
saying officially today there's more
people watching gamers than watching
sports let me say this one more time
there's more people watching gamers
today than watching sports so let's go
back go to when you and i were 14 years
old go to when you and i were 14 years
old go to the 14 year old gerard the 14
year old adam the 14 year old tom tom
ricky the 14 year old go to that age
right and then make that today what
would you and i be doing today if we're
14 years old when i was 14 years old we
were uh at show canyon playing baseball
with armond and arton and all these guys
trying to see who can hit that home run
over that fence and shoal canyon when i
was 14 years old we were playing at arty
white trying to dunk on an eight-foot
rim because it was a junior high school
not even a junior high school it was a
middle school and we could dunk you know
those rims that were lowering your life
and a half sick eight and a half right
it was sick you would play over there
with all these guys when i was 14 years
old we were jumping the fence and going
to the swimming pool at the high school
and we were swimming when i was 14 we'd
go to tommy's burger and buy thomas even
though we were broken when i was 14
years old we were going to a store
called beckett off of broadway and we'd
buy baseball cards we'd go to another
place that was a batting cage of i think
was called camelot and we would play
base remember that camera or yeah
when i was 14 so i'd walk to glendale
galleria and walk around and go to
haagen-dazs and get a job at the
freaking hawkins that's what we did i
played fester's quest i made a piece
with peter tunney on my house that's got
fester's quest there because i played
hundreds of hours playing fester squads
didn't get paid [ __ ] for it because
nobody's how great i was you know i
played super mario kart but i tell you
if i played fester and if i was 14 today
playing festers quit and all of a sudden
i got 17 million people watching me i'm
probably gonna play fester's quest and
dominate the festers quiz so we have to
know what direction we're going the
first time i heard about the whole nft
thing like what are these guys talking
about i interviewed
people who sold it for 69 million and i
only met a covenant who's a volunteer
from singapore who bought it for 69
million who's a bitcoin billionaire i
interviewed both of them within a span
of a week or something to see both of
their perspectives and medecovin talked
to me he was the first if you've never
seen this interview you have to watch
this interview he's the first guy that
made me say
i have one of those moments where i'm
sitting there talking to you i'm like
this guy freaking makes sense
this guy makes sense he says patrick
where do you live right now do you have
a nice house i would assume you have a
nice house well one day you're going to
close your eyes and there's going to be
people spending more time in their world
meta world than they're going to the
virtual world than they're going to in
the real world and in the virtual world
you're going to own yourself a
waterfront house you're going to have
friends you're going to have features
you're going to do certain things and
there's going to be museums and i'm
going to own one of the most incredible
museums and for you to come inside my
museum and watch and see the every days
that i bought from people for 69 million
dollars you have to buy a ticket to see
it but the only way you see it it's
going to be the last room in my museum
for you to see it in my world and you're
going to have to buy the ticket to go in
and see it
here's a guy that's worth a billion
dollars on crypto is sitting there
saying i bought this thing for 69
million dollars we are living in a
different world so let's transition into
this meta story and and see where this
is going to go and that's going to be
interesting gerard i'm going to go to
you first on this one here so let me
just get right into this on page one
guys with facebook what was just
announced by the is it fair to say that
all you guys seen the the video with the
zuck and what the cnet video was one of
them is a six minute one the other one's
a 12 minute one you both you've all seen
it okay fantastic facebook is changing
its name to meta as it focuses on the
virtual world a washington post story
last week facebook changes corporate
name to meadow moving aggressively to
distance itself from a social media uh
business enrolled in crisis and rebrand
itself as a forward-looking creative a
new digital world known as a metaverse
in a 75-minute online presentation zuck
urged users to adjust their thinking
about the company which he said had
outgrown its ubiquitous and problematic
social media app a platform that will
continue to be known as facebook instead
he said the company plans to focus on
what zuckerberg described as a next wave
of computing a virtual universe where
people will roam freely as avatars
attending virtual business meetings
shopping in virtual stores and
socializing and at virtual get-togethers
don't forget that when philip morris
changes name from altria
it was still selling cigarettes that
caused cancer tweeted democratic lawyer
mark elias and there's a few other
things here about the meta i'll pause a
little bit
but we'll go to that part right there so
there's some people that are excited
about it some people that are not gerard
your thoughts on meta
it's inevitable and it's you talk about
like a disruptive technology look at how
much time
people spend online right now right now
you know you have uh you know uh i know
guys man that day as soon as they get
home from work the first thing they do
is they get in the gta they've been
playing gta for two three years now
they've got millions of gta dollars
they've got millions they've got
hundreds of gta cars they've got houses
they have this entire sub life where
their gta life is like their real life
grand theft auto same thing with world
of warcraft and i think this metaverse
is going to make that technology
to the next generation seem like what
nes is to us like you know how like when
when sega first came out and we were
like these graphics can't get any better
my god it's incredible and now you look
at the graphics today and it's insane
this metaverse
you're gonna have a generation of people
who just literally lay on their couch
like they're hooked into the matrix and
they walk around with their eyes closed
all day they have relationships online
they'll have sex online they'll have
jobs online they will they will wake up
there will be people that work in the
metaverse they will the only time that
they will be out of out of the oculus
the only time that they will be in
reality is when they have to eat they
have to [ __ ] and they have to sleep they
may even be able to sleep in the
metaverse i i know that that sounds
draconian i don't necessarily know that
it's bad i think it's bad i think you're
gonna have society kind of drift into
two different directions in two actual
realities you're gonna have a reality in
the the functional world the real world
if you will in a completely separate
reality probably with different rules
different governments in this digital
reality i think the actual world itself
is going to split into two simultaneous
realities
let me ask you what what what has
dramatically changed in the last 40 40
years let me ask the question and you
give me something say four or four four
zero four years what has dramatically
changed in the last four years okay so
how we how we uh communicate with each
other obviously because of social media
dramatically internet email internet
fine okay cell phone's fine uh
how about dating has dating dramatically
changed in the last 20 years forget
about 40 years so dating absolutely
tinder 10 years ago today okay fantastic
let me ask you this so what were some
things that happened that parents were
worried about parents were worried about
rock and roll music with elvis presley
hips moving it's going to get girls to
do this what if my daughter does this
okay has music changed dramatically from
80s i want to know what love is to now
hey i was you know doing your girl with
my gucci
so you know hit him up is slightly
different than you know uh uh
what do you call it uh yeah whatever
songs you want to talk about right
faithfully or don't stop believing it's
a very different uh
narrative with the songs okay how much
has porn changed has porn changed over
the last four years
i know i mean nobody at the table's
watching but for the people that do
watch porn what i do know is tom knows a
lot about marijuana for whatever reason
gerard knows a lot about porn i don't
know what it is okay but but here's a
question though how much has porn
changed the last 40 years okay so go
back 40 years ago 40 years ago was what
vhs la express playboy magazine hustler
all of these things so how's it changed
now then it went to
vhs then it went to let's just say
napster then it went to
you know cds then youtube not youtube
but uh uh pornhub whatever how much has
it changed though has it changed really
that much
i know but has it dramatically changed
has the experience changed it's still
you
you know as a single man or person
that's watching it you're consuming so
the part where i'm going with this is
your experience has changed
significantly but in on from the ten
thousand foot view no at the end of the
day it's still you and you are by the
way you just gave me more that's what i
was going with this vr point is
metaverse by the way but the part i was
going with you is the following how much
has uh uh being a dancer 20 years ago
versus today is it even worth you
dancing today instead of being on
pornhub i don't know how strip clubs
exist that's nice
but that's that's that's something
that's really a business model so do you
think people are still want to go see
the real strip club versus going on
pornhub okay all right so perfect if
you're saying yes do you think a 20 year
old i wonder if the demographics show
the younger generation is as excited
about strip clubs as 40 year olds are i
don't know okay so then then we have to
go and try to think like an 18 year old
20 year old today
with what meta is going to do and how
they're going to process this with
versus us because to them it's going to
be normal to us it's kind of like weird
right so we have to think
like the people who think it's normal
not just think like us who think this
[ __ ] is weird right so how much has it
really changed for them
i can see it being to the point where
like the government has to regulate
how much time you can spend in the
metaverse because people will spend 20
hours a day in the metaverse it's so
much better than their regular life
you're born into poverty you're short
you're fat you're whatever and in the
metaverse you're tall you're attractive
you're you're rich they're going to live
their life there as opposed to in the
real world so much so that the
government will probably regulate you've
been online for 10 hours and then
they'll be black there'll be there'll be
black market metaverse
places where people can go into
somebody's basement and hook back in
it's a drug they even talk right now
video games are drug there's that
athlete that lost his career because he
was playing the tight end for the for
the broncos he literally had a grand
theft auto addiction he was like i
skipping practice to play grand theft
auto it was serotonin in his brain
it was
dude the the
we we're all addicted to our cell phones
we're addicted
but okay so folks if you're listening to
this i'm actually curious i want to read
your commentary what are your thoughts
what's your biggest matter of fact
what's your biggest concern and then
we'll talk about you know the the stuff
that could be good i'll make one more
point cause i've been talking too much
but the the
we talked about this when was the last
time remember when you would come home
and your there would be one phone and
somebody would call during dinner your
dad would get so pissed off and he'd
take the phone and put it off the hook
so nobody else could contact you that
night yeah what was the last time our
phone's been off the hook
yeah never well i'll give you i'll give
you another perspective here the the
rules of the game have changed back you
said what's the difference between 20
years ago 40 years ago back in the day
the rules were completely different
they've been flipped what were the what
were the rules don't get in cars with
strangers don't meet random people
online
get out of your house and do things and
play now it's
you know you're getting in cars with
strangers ricker's getting doing
business deals learning last names while
he's in cars
right
people are meeting people online on the
regular that's how people date these
days you know speaking of not getting
out of your house now you're locked down
in your house the rules of the game have
changed but
that
you know facebook has basically put the
world on notice that they are coming
after the future they are not just a
social media platform at this point
where you can you know rate hot girls or
be friends or check the news they're
basically saying live your life in our
world now right and this is what mark
like
mark zuckerberg
more than anyone with this this move
right here i could see taking over the
world people talk about elon musk or
jeff bezos mark zuckerberg is now coming
after your mind and your dreams and
basically your entire life with this
meta it's no longer facebook like a sims
game almost
it's the matrix it's avatar and and
there's parts of it that like hey wake
up see what's going on here you know
tico's living in this world right now
and there's parts of it like if i'm a
boomer out there and i'm thinking
what the hell is going on here if
there's anything we've learned from this
past two years of zoom meetings and how
effective it is and hey you can just be
anywhere
there's something the fact that we're
sitting here hey how you doing pat we're
touching yeah let's not forget about
humans need interaction and this
metaverse is cute and all but at some
point you need to get out of your house
and do real stuff okay somebody just
said mr bruce kim and i want to hear
from others gerard to see what others
have to say as well i'm going to go to
them
tom tom i'm going to come to you ricky
if you got thoughts i want to hear from
you as well so here's what some people
have to say matthew mason said zuck is
influenced okay stefan kariva said real
player one which i don't know if you've
seen that movie or not yeah it's
actually very interesting yes um
marisol esparza said obesity is a
concern for our children mr bruce said
meta is evil uh uh trc turtle island
said will durant the age of decedents
which i've read a lot of will durant
back in the days so uh
this is cj death first time i've ever
heard a comment like that adam is wrong
the next one andy h it's not the real
world it's a jail it's matrix okay dancy
anthill said control freak rules so look
you know it's it's concerning but you
know sometimes parents are worried about
losing their kids like it's like i'm
gonna lose my kids
this is one of those things where you
can actually lose your kids and the
attention tom what are your thoughts so
as a parent what are you thinking about
this well i've been worried i spent a
little bit of time in video games and um
in the industry and i can take you back
to march 1999 which was the origin of uh
sony online entertainment to everquest
and everquest was
one of the first massively multiplayer
online role playing games where you had
an avatar you collect stuff you buy
weapons you buy things you
and people will go in that and they
would be playing for 20 hours straight
um
true story and it unlocked for me
understanding you know what the human
human capacity for addiction and
and to be to satisfy something beyond
yourself has never changed our ability
as humans to be addicted whether it's
video games or drugs or music or
something and you get so immersed in it
that it's that it's there
now
that that really worried me there were
people that had stopped playing
everquest that were still paying 19.99 a
month and people would say why are you
doing that you're paying 240 a year yeah
i don't want to lose my avatar i got my
avatar i got all my activity i got
everything in there and that told me
right there just how scary it was and i
started seeing you know fortnite
remember fortnite fortnight first came
out you know and you dropping into the
island fortnight and baseball guys do
you remember when there was two of those
consoles it was in the boston red sox
locker room and they were playing it and
david price missed a start because he
had cramping in his thumb wow because on
that thing they were he was playing
fortnight to 3 a.m he comes to the david
price was cy young was he a cy young
woman or no i thought he was a side well
he was a woman
i worked at 10 pitch david price one
time so i i am i think as a parent you
better put timers and you need human
interaction and you should put timers
and restrictions on your kids getting in
these immersive video games because the
gaming industry knew in 1999 there's
billions and billions of dollars to be
made off your kids because of our
natural how much worse is this though
that's what i want to know is this like
it is nine times no it's a hundred times
worse because zuckerberg is involved all
right and i agree with adam he wants to
take over the world here's his biggest
problem he's the world's worst salesman
he literally is he has no charisma you
automatically hate him if you know his
track record so he's not going to be
able to sell people on this new con
concept i don't like him you know i i'm
less interested in meta if he had
someone with
it would be different if elon musk was
in front of this i mean you might
believe it or want to get into it hey
the whole thing the whole world you guys
are describing is scary to me uh my kids
aren't allowed to play fortnite i never
let them spend any time playing those
addictive games there's no way i prefer
the real world
i prefer human beings it's just the way
it is and that's
not going to change and i can understand
i mean this is just a trap this is a
jail cell for young people that are
going to get sucked into this they're
going to remain single their whole life
they will be able to live their whole
life inside this metaverse and
zuckerberg knows it
so you know this is a convenient way for
him to rebrand the company which he's
still going to be all involved in
facebook i mean that's not going away
what they do but it's a marketing move
for him and and i think him as the
world's worst salesman which he is um
he's not going to be able to rule that
let me tell you something as much as i
agree with you
for being the world's worst salesman
he's doing a lot of sales he's doing
okay no but i'm like he's doing pretty
on camera i'm talking about when she is
front and center i know his company is
doing great of course it is he's got the
best engineers in the world i'm talking
about him as the face of i i i don't
think that's hard to argue with
you made a great point and whoever did
that super chat is right about it being
a little bit of a jail look at how
they're controlling information right
now look at how they're controlling
speech say the wrong thing you're shut
down imagine being addicted to that
metaverse this is where you're online
this is where your job is this is where
your girlfriend is that's online you're
dating somebody in in three you know 5
000 miles away halfway around the world
they they're on the metaverse you're in
love with this life but you said the
wrong thing so now we're going to shut
you down for 30 days you can't get on
the metaverse you can't go to work you
voted the wrong way
you you you you ate red meat it was
detected in your your our bio stands
detected that's the social credit score
that they're doing in china exactly but
in the metaverse now exactly they'll
throttle your reach here you are all
your friends it is
it is very scary as people who have
grown up in the real world yeah the
thought of this yeah pat made up a good
point if you're 12 15
you you've got kids all between you know
six and 15 like this this is quite the
concern if you're if you're a parent let
me let me okay so that's that's that's
the part that's the part i read a uh
time magazine article that said uh
minimalist how the next generation is
minimalist and this was like eight years
ago seven years ago and in the articles
no not not minimalist it was talking
about narcissist had the next how
narcissists they are and they were
talking about all these 14-year-old kids
want to do is take pictures the lips the
duck face all this other stuff and you
know these kids are spoiled and you know
they're having issues because all they
care about is how many likes they're
going to get and that i don't know it's
such a problem it's catastrophic and you
know how the article ends
if you
think this is catastrophic and it's the
end of the world maybe it just means
you're too old yeah so so you ain't
that's the that's the hardest thing that
for us we have to consider because every
time something new happens we think it's
the end of the world okay we think it's
the doomsday and my only challenge to
all of us is i don't know if it is i
don't know if it's not but i will tell
you what's the biggest mistake if you
don't immerse yourself to learn about
this world you're screwed because the
biggest thing is to be ignorant about it
it's better to be you know learning
about it so if i'm a parent i'm
definitely learning about this stuff
more than anybody else is because i want
to find out what the hell is going to
happen you're losing your kid your kid
is sitting there two hours upstairs not
coming downstairs he's got this stuff on
his eyes and you know like he's oculus
to whatever it is that they're looking
at it yeah i don't know i don't i i
don't know but basically saying the last
thing that you should be is dismissive
think about all the people who have been
dismissed it would be big crypto
whatever nfts how ridiculous is that
that's never going to work over the last
handful years and you're dismissing
people's perspectives and feelings and
you're missing out on the opportunity i
think being aware you said something a
few podcasts back which is really great
right the the people who are paranoid
survive right the paranoid survive so i
think it's i think it is good to be
skeptical and cynical about these things
but at the end of the day it's a tool
right it's technology and you can use it
for amazing things you were talking
about zoom yeah but there's something
about being here yes that's going to put
you here we're going to all be sitting
next to each other we're going to feel
each other we're going to see each other
you know what i mean so listen why don't
we do why don't we do an oculus 2
giveaway how about we do that an oculus
2 giveaway literally if you give twenty
dollars to the super chat which we've
already said if we get to ten thousand
dollar ten thousand live
we'll give away ten thousand dollars
matter of fact here's what i'm gonna do
if we get to 7 500 live i'll give away
an ethereum how about that i'll give one
ethereum away to anybody if we get to 7
500 is that okay with you hey
tell your friends
but to participate you got to do a 20
super chat
so okay so let's do one right now right
now right now what we're doing right now
we're going to do the what do you call
it we're going to do the oculus 2
virtual reality
giveaway with a signed book so adam not
adam uh samvel if you wanna put that up
so we can take a look at it it's the
next giveaway
can we give a quick shout out to kai
he's misspelled nothing today on
fire first of all he hasn't been asked
to spell anything there we go
there we go
all right so jose is the last winner
let's see what we got let's see how many
names it's going to be now check this
out look at it boom put it
up
here we go baby
who is it
is
oculus 2 that's it gerard's porn
experience about to change
okay so oculus 2
this seems a little scripted right now i
don't know
good good thing it wasn't the ps5 again
[Laughter]
okay well listen we keep going so now
gerard's out of it what are the chances
of one of the guys winning
gerard gave ten thousand dollars to be
in there a bunch of times
oh my god all right so gerard no audrey
davis no tiki no launching let's
continue guys if you want to be in the
next uh uh raffle that we're doing super
chat 20 bucks we're getting a lot of
rigged comments right now
we're getting a lot of risks
it's not rigged it's fortified so okay
we get to 7 500 it will be and ethereum
we'll get to 10 000 it's ten thousand
dollars cash but we only have an hour
and 20 minutes left in the podcast i
can't believe that
stop it i told you what i tell you this
is an insurrection at its finest right
now
yahoo pulls out of china citing
challenging environment pretty
interesting for yahoo to make a story
out of this by the way this is an ap
news
story the withdrawal was largely
symbolic as many of the company services
were already blocked by the china
china's digital censorship but recent
government moves to expand its control
over tech companies generally including
his domestic giants may have tipped the
scales for yahoo yahoo's the latest
foreign company to exit china google
gave up several years ago microsoft's
professional networking platform
linkedin said last month it would
shutter its chinese side replacing it
with a job board instead the departures
illustrate the choices internet
companies face in a huge potential
market but one where the government
requires them to censor content and
keywords deemed politically sensitive or
inappropriate chinese laws stipulate
that companies operating in the country
must hand over data if requested by
authorities making it difficult for
western firms to operate in china as
they may also face pressure back home
over giving in to china's demands okay
so uh zenner i'm going to you first and
i'm going to ricky okay
oh start talking now
i was in the meta verse my bad
let me exit real quickly and deal with
humans third dimension um
clearly it's becoming very difficult for
tech companies to uh interact with the
chinese government and
take away the population 1.3 billion the
biggest market in the world for them to
be bailing this quickly uh speaks
volumes you know so i'll let you guys
talk more about it i'm waiting for the
chinese taiwan porn
math teacher and then i can really give
you something yeah you are tom yeah
i think if you if you if you
if you um
really compare what's going on in china
and what's going on here tom what it's
not it's it's really
no different because what america is
using is just pressure what the with
uh uh as far as what you can say what
you can't say the chinese government is
just simply telling you you're not going
to do it
american government is not doing that
but what they're doing is they're
grabbing the media and telling you you
can't do that i don't know if they i
don't know if i'm making sense yes yes
america is doing the same thing
yes so it's like chinese government are
just like straight up don't care
and with us
we're we're experiencing the same thing
as china except that we're using
uh the social um
justice warriors to do it i think that
to me that's
it's like it's like there's two cars are
speeding one china one in america right
in america
the guys in the cars next to you start
yelling at you and they're pointing at
you in china they hit the remote control
button and your car stops that's it
i mean it's it's really if you look at
it it's really no different uh and as a
matter of fact uh uh tick tock the the
guy the that's the mic i came over the
guy from tick tock he was just
interviewing they were doing all the
fight dance yes
so so the guy would take dog and then so
he was at the senate floor
and i think it was uh j i think it was a
senator kennedy or if not it was uh
from texas uh not not ted cruz oh my god
i can't forget i'm drawing a blank john
cornyn no no i think he's from texas uh
like hardcore he's like another kennedy
republican no hispanic guy uh what's his
name uh i can't remember he's cuban
oh my god i can't believe i'm drawing a
blank right now well he's interviewing
ricky he's gonna be okay make your point
he's he's repla he's he's interviewing
him
and and what they're doing is tick tock
sharing data with china on americans
and they're saying well
why can't we why can't we get your
information but you can get ours
and so he won't ask the question no we
don't share it's our mother company so
you're but but the requirements is that
you have to share all data with them in
the the main company mother companies in
china and tech talks in america so we've
been knowing that tick tock if you
believe general spalding if you are on
their fiber optic network right they
have your information let me let me ask
you this i got two questions for you
guys i got two questions for you guys
jenna's saying ted cruz but he said it's
not that cruz no it wasn't
apparently billionaire but anyways
that's a different story let's go back
talk about john cornyn who are you
talking about
let me know it's totally fine it's the
cuban guys that groups but here's the
point i got two questions for you i got
two questions
right so i got two questions you said
ted cruz yeah so i got two questions for
you two questions for you number one
question in this uh story here with uh
tick tock okay
which is yahoo but you guys brought up
tick tock so i got two questions one
how close was it for trump to shut down
tick tock in u.s do you guys remember
the time
do you remember how concerned people
were in america yes okay number two
in regards to tick tock do you think if
a
if a desantis or a trump gets elected do
you think
chance wise
do you think
they'll go after tick tock to shut it
down
give me a percentage highly likely
okay more than any social platform tick
tock is on the chopping block tell you
what i'd like to see them doing i can't
believe i'm saying this for government
interaction but after your conversation
with the facebook moderator the fact
that those guys have access to
everybody's conversations yeah that's
got that's got to go facebook are on
your phone anybody yeah yeah people out
there that's my question on i didn't see
it facebook messages whatsapp any
facebook instagram the guys
can see your message with anybody says i
said so who did you go and look at he
says i don't care about what people say
all i care about is what my cousin has
to say about me
so but here's the thing let me go back
to the question guys let me go back
because this is leading to a point so
what percentage what is the chances of
the next administration if a desantis a
trump a republican gets elected that
tick tock gets banned in the u.s i don't
know if i india has already done it
india banned 100 apps i don't know if
it's any republican i think it's going
to be the deceptive trump they're going
to go after you what do you think gerard
give me your percentage give me five
percent ten percent five okay uh senator
what's up 75. okay tom what do you say
i'm with zenner i say 75. what do you
say
well i don't think anyone's gonna do it
more than trump and trump was very close
so i'm saying 25 25 okay so now this is
the next question here next question
here in regards to yahoo leaving in
regards to microsoft leaving and
changing linkedin into a job posting
side whatever in regards to google
saying dude we've been out three years
we're not dealing with china and these
are liberal companies that are in china
so this is not political that we're
talking about here they're just leaving
because the business model doesn't work
here's the last question for you how
soon do you think
if ever hollywood leaves china
do you think anything will be a tipping
point for hollywood or sports absolutely
not we want to because that's where all
the money comes from if china cut
hollywood off that's how it would happen
but there's no way hollywood's cutting
down
what could cause what could cost for
hollywood producers executive producers
and the sports mba mlb nfl nhl to say
you know what we don't care about
getting that contract in china we're out
i think that they want to right now i
think that they really really want to i
think they're waiting for somebody else
to show them china or the us we talked
about this we talked about this with the
manning cast all the manning cast is and
it's massively popular the manicast is
just a live stream it's youtube it's
twitch it's national television taking
digital technology and implementing it
in their professional format so whoever
is the first person to deviate take that
disruption and deviate and say you know
what we're gonna go direct to consumer
forget the movie theaters we don't need
a revenue based model where people have
to go and buy popcorn we're going to
make something and it's going to be
pay-per-view if you want to see dwayne
the rock johnson you have to be on ricky
aguilar tv i got a 10 i got a 10 a 10 uh
movie deal with the rock he got paid 200
million dollars you got to see the rock
here and it's going to be 299 each of
his movies take me back to now something
sparks the sports leagues they want to
leave but they don't take me back to
that okay so the sports leagues
particularly right what right now what
they're doing is they're they they're
trying to figure out streaming rights
right you look at major league baseball
john boy media
actually pays for youtube streaming
rights to do all of the the highlights
it's remarkably cheap they've pivoted
away from where they used to hunt these
guys down and be like you're using our
rights it's a thousand dollars now it's
like oh it's free marketing for us yeah
it should give us like 20 bucks a video
and now you own the rights to it so they
have their product and then you're going
to have this micro streaming ecosystem
and somebody's going to aggregate these
places these people all together it's
going to be like if you like baseball
you have your 25 favorite streamers
that are watching the baseball game the
same time and you can click and you can
watch patrick call a baseball game if
you don't like joe buck you can watch
you can watch adam socks
it'll be the 11 months of pirate bay and
napster where they had all the illegal
music and you just went there and you
could see everything that is a perfect
example and pirate member pirate bay yes
and pirate bay and napster and bear and
bear those are the three that ended up
in handcuffs boom they were gone because
and then what came out of that itunes
and itunes they said the cds legal
napster the cd is dead i don't need espn
if i'm only watching one show why do i
need the whole channel you're going to
be able to buy per episode i don't i
don't want to i don't want to buy an nfl
network i just want to watch the
management so i understand
satellites
go back to pat's question about
if it's super specific leaving
china do you think you're somebody that
thinks about the stuff do you think
anything any singular event can happen
where all sports unite and they say
we're out of china kai think about it i
may come to you next i think it's i i
think it's a human rights thing i think
it could be taiwan i think it it's a
human rights thing and it's
talking about i think or there's a leak
in use of the data and the rest of the
world realize
holy crap that's what they can do with
all this data tom if you get away from
advertising revenue you don't need those
people you don't need 1.3 billion person
marketplace if it's vod three he's
asking about what would cause a sudden
unification and departure following
yahoo following google following tick
tock long story short make it more
profitable domestically how do you make
it more profitable domestically i think
you do individual consumer vodka
that's the business side pat was asking
me
and i think i think as soon as there is
a human rights violation as soon as
there's a massive leak where people
realize wait a minute all my stuff from
tick tock somehow ended up over there
and this is what they're doing but tom
that's happening now and nobody cares
everybody knows that that china uses
slave labor nobody nobody doesn't wear
things that are made in china everybody
knows that's what i'm trying to say to
you guys what i'm trying to say is okay
so again i think desperately if america
needs anything right now is a is one
enemy that the left middle right
everybody agrees on desperately we need
one enemy that everybody is convinced
this is the number one enemy what does
china need to do for everyone in america
to say what russia used to be 40 years
ago when the movie rocky came out that
china becomes out what do they need to
do kai
from a 23 year old incredible typer go
ahead tell us so um just to piggyback
first on what could the sports do i
think if
if more players like innes cantor
step up and on different teams
then they would create enough headaches
for the nba to maybe even consider just
pulling out because if china already
isn't showing all the celtics games
imagine if then a player on lakers a
player on some of the big teams and like
then they're not showing half the games
already at that point you've reached the
tipping point of maybe where ah you know
what maybe it's not worth it anymore
because then they've essentially
sabotaged enough to where it's now
you're playing like tetris and trying to
figure out what games can actually go
through and then you're just getting
pennies on the dollar anyway and at that
point they pull out and then that would
just have to be going center what do you
think
i think the only way it could
realistically happen is the the
government forced the nba to not do
business with china anymore sort of like
china does with their tech companies or
with our tech companies coming over
there here's the other thing i think
it's very interesting that dave silver
hasn't said adam silver hasn't said
anything about anna's canter yet nothing
right he got away with saying way more
radical things than the gm for the for
the rockets did at the time and then
look at the reaction to john cena with
his comment when the movie came out when
he had the comment about taiwan he could
not backpedal fast enough and apologize
and damn near start balling as he was
doing it so i think hollywood is more
entrenched in china with less chance of
them leaving i think the nba looks at it
like this if they can replace the
revenue stream that's the only way it
could happen okay so let me ask you four
questions taiwan guys can i can i make
four points here four questions here
okay
so i'm gonna i'm gonna write out four
four causes
of of that taking place tell me which
one of these are more likely of
happening okay of leaving china
permanently number one a government
regulation okay where the government
says you can't do it u.s government us
government number two is adam silver
going out there and going against china
okay number three is the face of the
league uh athlete a mike trout a
k.d a lebron a tom brady a patrick
mahomes type of guy or fan base coming
together and boycotting and saying hey
i cannot understand why you guys are
supporting china which of those four is
more likely to happen
which one of those four will have the
most influence i'll ask is it the
government no no is it silver
i i think the the fan base is least and
no the most okay
people awakening i can tell you what's
the least the face of the league because
the players association will hammer them
because the face of the league can say
what he wants he's still making 200
million with a shoe deal but they got to
protect everybody else in that union
well i'll just use a case example to
shout out to the biz doc of myself
i don't think most americans single mom
two kids just trying to pay her bills i
don't think she's thinking about china
on a daily basis
something more than anything that i've
learned since being on the pbd podcast
doing this every day is holy [ __ ]
flashing reds lights look out what's
going on for china you know we call the
china the ccp i think there should be
another c in there the chinese
controlling communist party if there's
anything you don't like being a
capitalist is someone telling you this
is what you need to do and this is how
you live your life they they want
control they're controlling their
population the next thing you know like
gerard says they want to control the
world so unless the single mom of two in
america in kansas wakes up and says holy
crap this is what's going on in china
we're just kind of sleepwalking through
life because you know this is not our
major concern but it should be at the
top of our list i think government's
number one on your list i i would put
government the number one most likely
reason it would have i'm i'm with zenner
because the fan base you know will be
fractured some will care some won't uh
the face of the league will be told by
the player's side the players union to
shut up
no
no commissioner holding streaming cable
satellite broadcast rights around this
globe will do it
but if they move on taiwan and we move
economic sanctions the government is
going to tell people to moderate
business with china because we're going
to try and pull them back in line uh you
would hope that they would but our
government i'm convinced half of them
are you would be surprised the economic
impact on the united states there are
industries such as semiconductor that
are going to be massively impacted if
china moves across there you think chips
are difficult now do you think chips are
expensive now let me tell you they're
not there are three things that they're
going after in china
one is this historical pride thing but
that's like number three number two is
market share of chips and number two is
the is to limit the alternative
manufacturing location number one's
control of information for sure and i
will say this and i agree with you and
this is the the beauty of this podcast
and this is what we can do we do a
terrible job i think we can all agree we
do a terrible job of this country
perhaps intentionally of teaching what
capitalism really is of saying the
consumer the fan base the consumer holds
all the power right the government
changes government it changes with the
wins right
the consumer decides quoting joe dirt
here by the way
it's the consumer that you need to pay
attention bro the consumer the consumer
can change everything tomorrow if you
decide that you know what
enes kanter is right forget china i'm
not buying a single thing from the nba
that's made in china and it wouldn't
take a lot of people i'd say i tell this
to people oh it's last call i i tell uh
i tell this people all the time it's
your cigarette with with student loans
if you guys really wanted student loans
to go away get get on a campaign and get
three percent of all people with student
loans to refuse to pay them back so you
can renegotiate so so in other words
from what we got from this discourse
back and forth
you think it's going to be people yes
you think it's going to be people you
think it's going to be the government or
people i think it's going to be a
republican government okay you think
it's going to be utah government
government you ricky uh
i think it's going to be the people you
think it's going to be the people so
i i always think i think i think it's
to me i think if uh uh you guys are not
saying face of the league i think it's i
think i think if a player comes out an
influencer look the law of ef hut and
maxwell would talk about the law of ef
hutton there is guys in the league that
have a voice if they say something
it shuts the whole thing down if lebron
which he'll never do he would never do
such a thing ever do such a thing to go
against china never he would never do
that but if a guy like him came out if a
kd came out katie's more likely to go
and say listen i just don't like what's
going on in china i don't support the
stuff i think kd is more likely to do
something like that i think in the nfl i
think mahomes is a values guy mahomes
would actually be capable of doing
something like that i think brady's a
guy that keeps his politics down but i
think one of those major influencers to
come out and then people agreeing with
each other that's something where
everybody has to pay attention i mean
look at what happened with daryl morey
that guy got cancelled immediately daryl
morris not a top 100 influencer in the
nba he's not and
kyrie irving is though and they're still
shutting him up kyrie's not a top top 10
influencer in the nba he's not pat the
problem with mahomes you need a good
quarterback to be able to step out but
he has nothing to play good lately it's
it's it's a shot right there he took out
himself what what's that ef hutton law i
don't know what that
is ef hutton is no eff button is there's
always somebody in the room that's the
influencer you have to find out who that
person is okay you have to find out who
the person is when they speak when ef
hutton would speak everybody would
listen the ef hutton of sports needs to
speak that has everyone's respect
whoever that ef hutton of sports is if
they talk everyone's going to say [ __ ]
all right we got to do something to make
this guy happy so the complete opposite
of a kaepernick kaepernick did a video
the other day talking about i don't know
if you guys saw that video or not
anyways complete different story maybe
we'll go into the virginia story next
but kaepernick said something uh and
everybody had to respond to it right so
take a person and that guy wasn't even
an ef hutton the guy wasn't even an ef
hutton but there's somebody that needs
to come out who is an effort to say
something like to get people to pay
attention to it anyways uh let's have a
special guest that's here today uh uh my
wife jennifer is here with us jen why
don't you come and join us okay
jennifer come grab a seat right next to
uh
where do you want him david you want uh
how you doing baby hi jen
congrats
yes okay this is jen is this the first
time you joined the podcast yes
like sitting at the table
so today today's been an interesting day
because today we had what what happened
mike yeah jen's got it we got to share
the mic here babe so somehow someone we
got to share to mike
so today uh uh uh uh i went to the gym
early in the morning baby that's yours
you want to put it on just to listen to
it so today we went to the uh i went to
the gym early in the morning and then we
had uh i had to come back we had dylan
that he had what was that thing today
was it the thanksgiving girl
thanksgiving chapel at school special
thanksgiving deal at the chapel at
school
and then uh right after that i was
heading to the podcast i was 10 minutes
late because of dylan's special chapel
deal okay but we're gonna go 10 or 15
minutes higher so so babe here's here's
what i kind of want to do for you matt
why don't you tell
the audience so if there was anything we
can give away today so far we've given
away an iphone okay
we were asking everybody on what some of
the prizes were to give away gerard had
some good ideas tom had some good ideas
uh you know adam said why don't we give
like a cat away i said it's technically
you know we're gonna have the wrong
people coming after us we just gave away
an iphone we gave away an oculus we gave
away a montecristo
what what do you think we should give
away to the ladies
on the table you can choose something
else give me something three five
hundred dollars a thousand dollars that
ladies would like that we can do maybe
we give that away in the next five to
ten minutes what would you say that
would be um how about like a um
like a like a small wallet um like a
luxury wallet like a gucci wallet or
something like that babe how much is a
gucci wallet
yeah what is this this is what this is
700 600 bucks is this gucci
this is fendi no fake funding
so you think what a gucci wallet what
about 6 700 bucks a nice little small
one nothing crazy
it was 450. would that be pretty cool to
do a gucci wallet can we see because
right after the gucci wallet we're going
to do the playstation 5. okay let me see
here gucci
you're right there that card case okay
that's the one that i just got that's a
gucci wallet marmont yeah
okay uh the one i got was like 450. is
there a chanel one or no is there
150 200 bucks what else give me one more
let's see how about something valentino
like uh sandals valentino sanchez so if
you had to choose between a valentino
sandals and the other one which one
would it be tory burch tory burch is way
more comfortable tory burch's okay give
me one more so so far we have the we
have the little uh what did you say the
purse the the wallet the tory bird
sandals what else ricky you and erica
shop all the time for the ladies give me
one more piece what else would you say
it's winter's a scarf a scarf is around
your body
scarf where you cut a couple hundred
bucks
louis vuitton scarves he has no one of
those one of those herm scarfs oh my
gosh look at that look at that look at
the louis vuitton uh scaf
by the way i just bought some hermes all
right
okay cool so here's what we're gonna do
the next giveaway exactly
the next giveaway is the final one
here's what we're doing the next
giveaway is going to be a louis vuitton
scarf okay it's going to be the tory
bird sandals and it's going to be
the gucci wallet all three combined is
that a good giveaway
we're going to do all three of them is
that okay if we do that yeah thirteen
hundred bucks
this one we know that it's freaking
rigged if jeremy starts walking around
in high heels
and paddy's in his pocket
this is rigged
let's let's do uh so in the next one
after this story we'll do the giveaway
for the ladies so so gentlemen you may
want to get it for your wife or your
girlfriend or ladies if you're on there
you might want to do the 20 because the
next one's going to be that will do that
and then afterwards we'll do the
playstation and then if we get to 7 500
i'll give away one ethereum okay okay
guys
all right so why don't we do a story
with jen here jen let's pick a story
that maybe you can uh give us some
opinions on as well all
right me see here okay how about shaq's
message to his kids is that a fair one
to do is that what we want to do let's
do that one okay let's do that because
we've talked about this so it's this is
a good one for us okay page three
our friend shaq who till today i'm
blocked because of the interview i did
with kobe you're still blind i am
shackled by shaq till today i'm blocked
by shaq he sent me a real
message he says what a stupid question
to ask kobe what do you mean if i had
kobe's work ethic who would i have been
that's the dumbest question i've ever
heard bam and he blocked me anyways all
right so let's go through shaq's message
to his kids
i'm rich we're not rich 17 kill news
former lsu tiger and basketball legend
shaquille o'neal delivered it's so weird
the introduction why would you say
former lsu tiger why wouldn't it be the
former laker nba hall of famer but
former lsu tiger and basketball agent
shaquille o'neal delivered some harsh
news to his six children he told them
we're not rich i'm rich on a recent
podcast shaq says they're kind of upset
with me not really upset but they don't
understand the retired hall of fame
hoopster says he wants his children to
make his own make their own way in the
world o'neil's net worth hovers around
400 million dollars but he has made it
very clear to his children he expects
them to all go to college and if they
have an idea that they want to invest in
they will have to pitch it to him just
like anyone else babe what do you think
about this story i think uh i think this
is getting very familiar we go much
better right there oh thank you
i think it sounds very familiar because
do you hear it do you hear it or no i
don't hear it i don't i don't hear it
let's give it your mic here just do this
babe okay
go for it okay oh it's better
okay
okay musical mics
sounds very um yes because we we
basically
talk about the same kind of principles
with our children um you know whenever
they're wanting anything we talk about
being able to earn that even small
things you know if they want to buy
something they're like well hey can i go
get the money from my uh piggy bank
those piggy banks that you put together
for them tico was like where's the key
to this mom because i want to buy you
know this video game or whatever it
might be i was like i don't know where
the key is ask your dad so it's about
the saving principles i intentionally
lost the key because hopefully we're
going to lose the key for like 10 years
for the safe just kidding i have the key
but it's in a place that i don't even
know but i think they understand that
they don't have the money because like
you know if there's something they want
to buy you'll say look we'll go buy it
and and the kids will be like well i
don't have any money dad i don't have
any money so i think you know they
understand that this is the most curious
one would you agree dylan's the one that
says hey daddy how much is this house
i'm like dylan who cares he says no i
want to know because my friends are
asking they say you're rich how much is
this house i'm not telling you how much
is this house somebody told me this
house is a lot of money daddy yeah
they'll say like daddy are you a
millionaire yet and then you'll say
by the way i got to tell you what uh
dylan said dylan goes like this dylan
says hey daddy are you a millionaire yet
i see yeah you know i would say yes he
says but you're not a billionaire like
batman yeah he says that batman's
already billionaire so he's out can you
imagine that never be good
yeah yeah we can never rise above the
opinion of our children
it is true it is true uh uh you know uh
senna sent us so funny senna's like
daddy i want a ferrari yeah
so that's great i said daddy who's going
to buy it for you baby you're going to
buy it for me i'm not buying it for you
yeah you buy it for me i said no you're
going to buy it for yourself yeah but uh
so you agree with what jack has to say
yeah absolutely and i know i've heard
the kids say other things like that like
cena says or dylan may say you know i
want a lamborghini and then you you'll
say like well who's gonna buy it for you
and he's like well i don't have any
money and he's like well you gotta you
gotta work to make the money to be able
to buy that so do you remember that one
time we're driving the car tikko and
dylan are sitting in the back seat and
uh
uh uh so i say i'm papa's there all the
kids are there and i say hey tico dylan
are we one day going to be in business
together like we all me you daddy all of
us are going to be in business together
take on dylan and say they look at each
other very seriously they say um that
it's a very serious question let us
think about it
it's good remember that he's like let us
think about it that's a lesson out there
to everyone out there you don't have an
immediate answer let us
and then ten minutes later i'm like wow
these guys are wanting to think so
they're talking to each other in a back
seat in the escalator i'm like so daddy
we talked about it i said okay what do
you guys want to do we're going to start
a business together not with you it's
just going to be
daddy good for you so they're trying to
say we're gonna make our own money we
don't need your help tom what do you
think about the story with chad you know
it's interesting jen that story you know
i can kind of relate to that because i
have that same conversation with dash
because i'm asking him if i can borrow
some money from him actually he'll buy
me some of the kids making money right
now but it is something that you have to
deal with for sure shaq's interesting
because remember
he was clearly motivated by the fact
that his dad didn't give a damn about
him right he had the song biological
didn't bother so he was raised by a step
dad a very strict military guy made him
what he is yep treats him as this but
it's interesting that he has that as his
background it reminds me of what daniel
craig said said recently when the bond
movie came out that he's had to leave
any money for his kids i just i find it
weird here's my question for shaq
you're the busiest guy in show business
there isn't a commercial you don't do
you run to atlanta do tnt all the time
you're a police officer here you're a dj
there how much time are you spending
with your kids because i've never heard
about any of your kids i'm kind of
surprised that none of them have started
to excel at something so i'm saying
playing basketball for them right now i
don't know i i i know a lot about
basketball issues okay play for ucla
that's right but i just you know when
you're not around your kids as much as
shaq isn't probably
and it's just such a throwaway line
saying you go make your own money you
give me a business plan if you want to
do something i i find it a little
callous that's just me personally i get
it yeah you know you want to make your
kids but that's not my style i got to
tell you i take the opposite of prayer i
absolutely love this the fact that he's
coming out and saying
i'm rich you guys you ain't nothing you
haven't proved anything to the world
there's nothing worse and this is why i
respect you guys so much making your
kids work for and earn it and read and
shoot hoops and baskets there's nothing
worse than entitlement and i've grew up
with a lot of rich kids in miami and
it's always the rich kids that don't
want to work for it that just kind of
feel like they're going to get the
inheritance that always end up resulting
into nothing and it's always the even
i'm not saying that all wealthy kids
won't turn out successful but it's the
ones that their parents implement some
work ethic and not the silver spoon
effect that always accept yeah but
you're you're making it seem like the
parents that just give their kids money
where they don't have to worry about it
it's the attention it's the focus it's
raising the right i think tom's talking
about extremities like that's the
extremity of like oh you're just gonna
not you know help him you know because
that's the point like for example my dad
two times in his life was what you would
consider rich to us right and so he uh
there was twice
and when the first time was when i was a
kid he owned the dealership he owned a
restaurant he owned four businesses by
the way he had no papers he was 28 years
old and not had no papers and he owned
four businesses and i
i i didn't know he had i was working
with the mechanic like at the he had a
dealership so when the cars would come
in i would help the mechanic i would
move the cars i would wash the cars so
my dad had money but i had no idea the
second time i was 12 i was like 12 years
old he got into real estate when the
real estate was booming
and he was he had 12 houses i was
working with the guys in the crew i was
putting up the stucco like my dad had
money i just didn't know i didn't know
until i became an adult that there was
twice because the market crashed and he
lost everything and lost everything
again twice um but he instilled that and
never did he say well he would tell me
one day this is all gonna be yours
but it's like but for now get your ass
to work does that mean like that's
that's the language one because he
didn't want to steal like i'm building
this for you but you're gonna you're
gonna earn it you know so that was a lot
of conversation with that like one day
it's all gonna be yours but then
meanwhile pick up that plywood now pick
up that sheetrock pick up that hammer so
i worked in the cruise after school and
he would pay me uh he would give me 50 a
day
a 250 a week and i would have to buy my
own stuff you know like hey that's you
know but one day it's gonna be yours but
you're gonna learn the value so that's
you know there's there's just two sides
of it my dad wasn't like shocked like
you're not going to have it but also he
wasn't like here you go no you're you
know you're going to learn the value of
a dog
what do you think about this uh you know
i think it's i think it's fun rhetoric
but i mean if i follow shaq on on
instagram and and you know he's around
his kids a lot at least at least
whenever he's around is because the
camera's on anyway who knows i don't
know it seems like they like it they
love it
like they enjoy his relationship yeah i
think that he is trying to look he was
born in newark he was you know he was
raised you know not he wasn't raised
crazy poor but but
you know he he thinks he's got an
incredibly hard work ethic and that's
probably he took umbrage with you by the
way dieters this is on you guys you know
there's three million of you you should
be peppering shaq on twitter every day
saying hashtag sit down with pbd
valuetainers this is what are you doing
guys this is apes together strong moment
here we need three million of you just
to pepper shack instagram and twitter
for the next two days tell them to come
sit down and piece it up the next sit
down after mafia states is pbd it's jack
all right so the look
the i think it's great to instill a work
ethic my father was the same way you
know you never you never got anything
you had to earn everything and it did
get as you got older and you understood
like it did become frustrating it became
frustrating like that all right he's
like well you know you got to earn it
i'm like that well what what's the deal
like what's the deal like can i have it
or not like what are we doing here so i
think
look i i'm not a parent i don't know how
it goes you got to be a teacher you have
to teach them you have to instill them
discipline is everything you you want
you know we talk about the pat we've
talked about this extensively like how
do you
give you when you give your kids
everything you never had
they become everything that you never
were talk about we talk about that a lot
you know so it's like how do you your
success comes from your struggle but
your kids are never going to have that
struggle and you can't really emulate
that too much because then they'll grow
to resent you right so i tell you i
don't know i like what he does his kids
seem to love him i think he walked that
you know that's kind of like every great
coach every great mentor every great
boss every every great friend you've
ever had knows when to push and knows
when to pull right
good feedback there uh ladies if you
folks if you're watching this in about
five minutes we're going to do the next
giveaway which is going to be what a
louis vuitton uh scarf it's going to be
the tory burch sandals and it's going to
be the gucci a wallet which is like 1300
we'll do that your next 20 super chat
you'll be in the raffle you've got
probably five more minutes to get that
twenty dollars into being the next super
chat here's what i would tell you
a guy named art williams who is the
founder of ao williams he used to be
with a company called larry uh uh wydell
and reed and then he left and it became
primerica city group bought it all this
stuff it's term insurance company
this is to just do it guys that's right
that's just the guy yeah art williams so
he said when he was a coach and he was
working with coach bear bryant or he was
a coach himself
he would tell us players you better get
your ass off the field if you're injured
don't even think about if you're injured
to lay down there get up and get to the
sidelines don't even walk slowly to the
sidelines i'm not going to come and get
you you get your ass up and get to the
silence that's what he would say he says
but in a leadership recording he said
the following he said but let's face it
if i knew they couldn't get up i'm going
to go pick them up and bring them to the
sidelines but you never tell them to
believe that because you want them to
use as much of their own sheer strength
to stand up so a big part of parenting
could be listen dude you got to figure
this out think up for yourself you got
to pull yourself you know you got your
little red wagon to pull whatever
michael's legacy the aguilar the center
legacy the elsewhere legacy but david
you know one day sasenic legacy you got
to go do your part but if [ __ ] hit the
fan you know who's the first person
that's going to go yeah you know it yeah
you know if something happens his son
needs something you know you're the
first person to go there so but the
tricky question is the following here's
a tricky question do you guys believe
you're going to leave inheritance to
your kids yes whatever whatever you have
are you going to leave 100 with your
kids no no whatever you have are you not
at the hundred percent part absolutely
not where are you at you're out there
they don't need to wait for me to leave
them an inheritance for kim and i to
leave them inherited yeah because we're
giving them vision purpose and education
and i've pointed out to them that says
look you got to go get your grades you
get your test scores so that you have
the maximum number of opportunities
whether that's college or whatever it is
in life you want the maximum
opportunities
you need to to work to get it and i and
i've sent bailey articles and student
loans i said you are blessed because
you're not going to get out of college
with student loans so you won't have
that burden as you produce the
opportunity following your education and
so that i give them purpose i give them
vision and we teach them consequence if
you if you slack now you're going to
limit the number of opportunities you
have you work hard you can't have the
maximum number of colleges you're going
to do 100 you're going to do a hundred
percent you're going to do a hundred
percent here's why
i don't know who else would be more
worthy than my kids i i mean unless
there's some charitable cause or
something okay or something well let me
ask you a question are you going to do
well give your kids all your all your
every uber you know like frequent flower
miles you have are you gonna give all
your money 100 to your kids no i don't
think a hundred percent what would you
give them
certainly some inheritance but okay
people forget how long people live and
you're gonna use a lot of your money not
everyone has 20 million dollars or ten
million dollars
when you're getting why when you die is
your estate gonna say a hundred percent
of your money goes to your kids or is it
gonna go to some charity i assume most
people if they're doing well they have a
trust and they have a trustee and i'm
gonna go to you guys
is it going to go 100 to your family
wife and kids
a large portion
so then here's the other question
here's the other question let me give
you the other question i'll give my
answer as well here's the other question
the question this is the real question
you got four kids
you got two kids you got three kids you
got 10 million in your state 20 million
in your state are you giving every kid
equally the same amount oh
that's a good question that ripped my
family apart man the ugly one has to get
the lease
you're calling one of your kids
chances are
that's cool they're going to come back
to see this video i want to hear the
story how this rip his family was not a
lot of money it was not not a
significant amount of money but my my
mom is one of eight kids
and my grandmother my grandmother only
left uh six of them
uh money and left two people out left
two people out and there was property
that she only gave to three
and
i gotta be honest and i love my
grandmother more than any human being
that's ever walked this face of the
earth i love that woman to death that
was a vindictive move but what was it
what was that
what was a reasoning
did she have one do you know her
reasoning she had reasons and then
afterwards
it was the the brothers and the sisters
got together and they were like you know
look grandma had dimension at the end
she was angry
look let's just do the right thing and
split this thing evenly and
some of the people were like no we're
gonna we're going with her last wishes
and they're like you're greedy it has
nothing to do with greed it's we're
honoring our mother's wishes and it
ripped the family apart until today till
today
won't go to each other's funerals like
like
rip them apart they'll never speak to
each other my family i'm telling you
that we spent christmas together we
spent every holiday interesting
no matter how far on long island about
how far south they got this was a tight
tight title horrible position to put
your mother in where she has to go ask
for something that she probably deserved
or if you're if you're gonna keep people
out you gotta tell them why i think i
mean there's got to be a reason for it
relationship broke down early before i'm
interested tom like you're not afraid
that you're your daughter and your
daughters love you to death you're not
afraid they're going to resent you if
you
you they know that what money you have
and that money is going to leave the
family and at least you could like leave
them in the will say here's everything
this is what i would do with it i would
say i'm giving 100 oh okay so
i'll tell you i'll tell you what we're
doing he says it's going to be a trust
or a foundation depending on the size
and there will be something for bailey
something for brooke and then they will
be trustees of the trust in the
foundation and we are going to already
be instilling in them in the things that
we support and the things that we do
they will already be unless i die in a
plane crash tomorrow afternoon
right they will already be instilled
conditioned
right we're already going to teach them
what we're doing and so when that's when
it's over they don't have to wait for
the reading of the world they'll say
well i've got something here i've got
something here i have no education debt
hopefully i've made something myself and
then we're both trustees to keep doing
what mom and dad were doing from the day
that we were old enough to understand
what they did with their money i i i
think so i had a story for one and then
we'll transition to the to the you got
two more minutes uh folks if you want to
get that uh tory burch sandals uh what
is it uh louis uh louis louis
and a gucci wallet we'll go around two
minutes here so that's for every woman
valuetainer and every persian
one of the successful uh of friends of
the family we had in iran was a lady
named shirin they had a son named ali
who ended up being a doctor and i don't
know what the sister's name was could
have been hirsa or something like that
anyways
so the way they did it is
they said it was so interesting my mom
told me the story they gave their wealth
while they were alive because they
didn't want their kids to be think
waiting for them to die so they get the
money
so they gave it while i think that's a
great idea yeah so they're like you know
what listen here's what we have here's
the money you're getting right now while
we're alive let's just enjoy we don't
want you to be like when his mom died
one is that then yeah so you know that's
one part but the other part also like if
you got a kid that ends up being being a
bad habits drugs all this other stuff
you're gonna give he's gonna ruin his
life there was a book by jim stovall
called the ultimate gift yes it's a
great book it's a great book we've
probably given a few thousand copies of
this book away i think you gave that to
me like the first week we were dating as
well that's right i probably did the
ultimate gift yeah this is gave you a
book first week of dating he gave me
several books yeah but the first week
this is the first book yeah the first
was 101 questions yes before you get
engaged
wow that's the second date second date
had borders he came on strongly yes uh
he he knew what he wanted to do yeah
second date and then we had a meeting
saturday for how many hours uh like six
maybe six hours we went through every
question not a date a meeting i like to
just have a meeting
i love how you tell a girl you give her
the ultimate gift and you hand her a
showed up her lawyers showed up it was
very romantic
both legal team was there we had a
mediator off to the side a court
reporter by the way jen
you know sena says you're going to give
me a corvette or a ferrari pink ferrari
you know when she does her little daddy
that you know if there's one kid that's
going to get it at senate i don't know
about that i don't think we would do
that to her no you don't know me too
well no no no i think santa could pull
it i'm saying if there's one kid that
can pull it out of here let me let me
explain it to you though here's how i
work the way i work is very simple
we have in every possible way it's all
about incentives you hit it i want to do
more for you i don't want to do less for
you i'm all about more so if you wanted
xyz i want to do even more but i want
you to hit a certain earlier numbers
performance giving your best behavior
attitude all that stuff i want to be
able to do that so there's going to be
some kind of a
structure for the kids to be able to get
more than others they're all going to be
in a pretty decent situation but some of
them are going to get more the others uh
business-wise here's how i'm going to do
when the guys have an idea to run a
business my approach for business is
going to be the following way you come
you don't talk to me you talk to him you
don't talk to me with your business
ideas because i don't have that kind of
relationship with you if you need me on
a chair no problem if you need me as an
investor no problem you have to convince
him you have to convince the lawyers not
me so you talk to them they hold you
accountable to the money they hold you
accountable to what you do
those guys are getting a fee of what the
company does good so they're not going
to be like oh here you go 17 million
here you go it's a million dollars here
you go 300 000
in return i'm in the back i'm just
simply the one that's the chair but he's
holding you accountable the board is
holding you accountable that's the way
i'm going to approach it with these kids
now we're going to find that in eight
years if it's right or wrong and then
we'll talk about it on the podcast
i said we talked about it in 2020
2 100.
by the way
you know what jack does that
this whole conversation started with sp
you know that he has something that he
calls the
shack tank
right it's like a shark tank
well he'll have he'll have investors
come in and pitch him for 15 minutes
while he's got his you know board of
trustees or his conglomerate around him
and they pitch him with ideas so that's
probably what he's gonna have his kids
do is come in and pitch the group on
their ideas he's not gonna give his kids
stuff for free there's gonna be an
incentive program we talked about dwayne
johnson being president one day i would
vote for shaquille o'neal as president
okay can you imagine shaq as a
press conferences would be great yeah
could he be the most dominant vote yeah
would he be the most dominant yeah okay
the first time i saw vladimir putin he
was in high school
i saw shaq play in high school right
before he went to lsu he played at the
u.s olympic festival he used to have
this in off olympic years he was on the
american team played at williams arena
mini minneapolis minnesota i went to the
game didn't know who he was there was a
half hour delay in the game because he
tore down the rim and he blocked 20
shots can you can you imagine shaq
against high school kids i saw it was
unbelievable by the way he lsu record i
think 14 or 15 blocks in a game i
remember that game when he did that he
was insane his former lsu tiger
by the way we went to a uh lakers event
with uh do you remember that lakers even
with shaq and james worthy came over
said hello that whole we were playing
basketball on the stables
yeah it was really cool great experience
shaq's the speaker shaq comes in he gets
up so shaq you know your kids you know
one of them looks like he's going to
have a career what college you're going
to put him into he says i'm going to put
him in lsu they pay the best
everybody was like quiet anyways
get in here it's time for raffle a bunch
of people are getting it inside
[Music]
history will be kind to me for i intend
foreign i want to see what's going uh oh
here we go
here we go a lot of names in there
ricardo
[Music]
whoever you are
comments
because you won't
he has donated around five times really
wow so he really earned it well
there you go buddy i'm sure your girl's
gonna be very happy maybe you may be a
girl that you got it happy for you as
well we'll send it over to you hopefully
you're in the state so we don't have to
worry about getting these scarves
closing in on vaccination cards so they
make it out to you okay
we got we got nearly 5 000 people live
here anyways okay babe i know you
probably gotta run it's been good having
you on here babe thank you appreciate
you thank you jen clap it up yes thank
you guys
if you want to see jen come on the
podcast more often give us a thumbs up
and subscribe to the channel and let us
know what you want to hear from her
because she's got a lot of insight the
only thing she can't talk about is how
i'm wired and how our relationship is
anything outside of that is stuff we can
talk about fair again yes this is a
pretty private okay all right so next
giveaway which we'll do folks you have
about i'm gonna say 15 minutes the next
giveaway we'll do will be the
playstation 2.
uh uh david said playstation two people
wouldn't leave the podcast let's take it
to five s five is what we're doing today
as i said is better than the four s5
that comes with what david what does ps5
come from can you tell them what it
comes it it comes with what somebody
five comes with uh an extra dual shot
controller some headphones for your
everyday gamer and the highest and
latest ps5 200 gigs 800 gigs it's a
terabyte
is it really 800
fantastic fantastic okay awesome all
right let's get into the next story here
how about we talk about what happened in
virginia are you are you okay if we talk
about what happened in virginia i know
adam wants this story really bad okay
all right let's go through this so
politics go to page
five with what happened in virginia
congratulations for the virginians
republican glenn younkin defeats
democrat terry mcauliffe in high stakes
virginia governor election this is an
insider story
uh in virginia's gubernator election he
won
tuesday's race was the biggest test of
president joe biden and his party
strength since democrats won back in the
white house in november 2022 and the
senate in january ranking a wealthy
uh former private equity executive and a
co-ceo of the carlisle group as a
political newcomer and funded much of
his own campaign on the campaign trail
young and depicted himself as an
economic conservative and largely
avoided discussing former president
trump who lost virginia by double digits
in 2020 trump spokesperson liz
harrington shared a statement on twitter
saying that trump and young can get
along very well together and strongly
believe in many of the same policies at
the same time the biggest story believe
it or not wasn't the governor was a
lieutenant governor marine
veteran winsome sears becomes first
female and woman of color elected as
virginia's lieutenant governor cbs news
republican winston sears was elected as
virginia's new lieutenant governor on
tuesday now becoming the first woman of
uh a female of uh first woman of color
to serve in that position i'm at last
four awards for the first time in my
life cyr said an address to supporters
on election night what you are looking
at is the american dream the american
dream this is the not the first barrier
series as broken sears or u.s marine
veteran previously served in virginia's
house of delegates she was the first
black republican woman first female
veteran and first legal immigrant
woman i think she's from haiti she's
from jamaica a woman elected to that
position she says on her campaign
website when my father came to this
country august 11 1963 he came at the
height of the civil rights movement from
jamaica and he only came with a dollar
75 she said on the victory speech when i
joined the marine corps i was still a
jamaican but this country had done so
much for me i was willing
willing to die for this country how big
of a deal is this the fact that
republicans won virginia time i'm going
to you first i think it's a huge huge
deal that has implications going into
the midterm
and the democrats are in disarray um and
i'm gonna curse starting with the
sleeping [ __ ] you know everybody from
the top down
is freaking out about what's going on um
this morning i was reading james
carville came up and said we need to go
to the woke detox center because the
defund police lunacy and take lincoln
names off schools is being noticed by
mainstream americans and voters and they
don't like it on the other side the far
left where five percent are
um you know omar said we need to double
down because this race baiting that
defeated us by the way she said that
this race baiting that defeated us wait
a minute she's got that flipped over
and then tim kaine
uh democrat ohio he said let me tell you
folks we better get our act together
because this is the ghost of christmas
future wasn't tim king a vp candidate
yes he was six years ago wasn't he from
virginia at the time
and then now he's democrat ohio well you
know once upon a time hillary was in
arkansas then she was in new york yeah
and jfk jr was alive but look at that
you've got moderation from tim kaine
reasonable statement carville freaking
out saying hey all the stuff that we did
would defund the police and i'll take
lincoln of school is it bad and then
omar saying no no no we need to double
down it's like there's three parties in
a democrat party and they're all freaked
out but i'm so
really really proud to see a person
that that came over and she's lieutenant
governor now her speech her story i
think
to me that's the biggest story of the
election if someone comes from somewhere
and they can adam what do you think your
thoughts i think you're missing the uh
the biggest story is that this
uh non-politician came in there
and he actually ran as a traditional
economic conservative republican he did
not embrace trump at all and actually he
said i'm here for virginia let's keep
this election about virginia trump i
don't need you on this one buddy and
that's the playbook if you want to win
the general election if you're a
republican if you want to win your state
and saying hey trump i respect you thank
you for all you've done i'm good because
if because it's all about converting yes
if you're going to embrace trump and run
to the maga crowd sure you're going to
get that but you're not going to win a
state like virginia biden won virginia
by i think double digit points
a year ago one year ago and now terry
mcauliffe who was a the governor of
virginia what 10 years ago running again
lost to younkin the playbook here is
that you don't need trump to win you're
gonna get moderates like myself or
people that could go either way and say
you know what the best ideas are with
this guy junkin this guy um
tara mcauliffe shot himself in the foot
because he made a lot of comments about
parents and school and you know
critical race and and stuff like that
and people said i'm sick of that and you
have to j people like james carville
and um
[Music]
tim kaine but that wasn't the worst
thing he said
he told parents
that they have no business what he said
he said you know right
he made some bad comments correct like
that that clearly shot himself the foot
the the the bottom line is what i'm
saying is this guy won fair and square
he didn't need to
cozy up to trump in order to win that's
going to be the playbook for other
moderate republicans moving forward is
that look
fight your fight you don't need trump
there for you backing you up you can win
without trump and i hope to see that
happen hold on hold on hold on hold on
hold on virginia's a blue state
do you think the republicans won
you don't think democrats flipped that's
his point that's literally that's
literally what i just said republican
moderate republicans that you don't need
trump with moderate republicans you
didn't tell me you didn't say that
democrat are the ones that flipped
because that's what ended up happening
here i'm saying independents and
moderate democrats flipped yes yeah so
exactly
so so i think what he's saying is if he
had embraced trump those that flipped
may not have because of it precisely no
i don't i don't but i don't agree with
that
why is that tell us why i don't agree
with it because people are tired of the
woke left
trump or no trump people are tired of it
they're tired they're done of you
telling them how to live their life
trump or no trump i think virginia was
gonna flip yeah but i'll say this i i
think the republican strategist over
here i think does have a valid point
because look at california look at kayla
we're sick of the walk mentality too but
we didn't get rid of gavin newsom i
think this is a win for common sense
california
is a whole different demon all right
okay you can't compare it to virginia
okay let's talk about virginia for a
second i think this is a win for sanity
i think this is a win for common sense
if you have hope because he flipped this
thing in the last month or two i mean he
was way behind in the polls and when
this idiot mcauliffe went out there and
started talking about crt you know
telling the parents they have no choice
that was it the suburban mom says you're
done all right and that's how i think
it's going to be in other parts of the
country as well
i disagree i disagree and this is why i
i would hope that they're going to flip
because a lot of people have been
talking to me about that too that this
is going to be a purple state and it's
all new jersey i'm going to tell you why
i'm going to tell you why i don't think
that it is because
there are some strategists and i talked
to a couple of them and they're like
our policies worked they
jack citarelli only lost in new jersey
even though they called it even though
the votes aren't fully tallied yet
maybe 2 000 votes
he's had 10 000 people phil murphy alone
in the last four years has had
a hundred thousand people that would
have voted against him leave the state
so what they're saying is is now there's
four years where they can
widen that gap let's get more of these
independents out let's get let's
strengthen our base and let's get these
small business owners out let's get
these older people out let's use our
policies and what elon omar is saying
you know she's a dog whistle and she's
using coded language but what she's
saying is is that we need to primary
these moderates justice democrats that
far left they do not go after the right
they don't run in blue count in in
in purple areas and they don't run in
red areas they find blue strongholds and
they run far to the left of the
incumbent that's what they did with new
york and aoc aoc didn't un she wasn't
some young whipper snapper that unseated
a republican she wasn't some young
whiffer snapper that came in and shook
something up she took a district that
was democrat for 70 years and made it
socialist
they they run to the left of the left
that's what elon omar is doing and
that's what they're looking in michigan
right now where they're literally
burning documents they're actually
burning documents in michigan right now
because
you didn't see
but that works in districts that doesn't
work on a national or state level
nonsense it definitely works in the
state level and it works politics start
local and they branch and they branch
regional if you make it in untenable for
a voting base to stay they leave they
come to florida they leave they go to
north carolina so this 2000 remember
there's over a million over one million
more registered democrats in new jersey
than republicans there's more registered
democrats in new jersey than there are
registered any other political
affiliation combined outside of
independence and they and he won by two
thousand votes after a hundred thousand
people left in the next four years if he
does the mandates again if he shuts
businesses down again another hundred
thousand are gone by the end of next
year it actually it actually strengthens
his power
to hurt his state i mean so that's
that's something you got to be very very
aware of the the actual politics the
political machinations behind this you'd
like to see it but what i do hope on a
federal level with the midterms coming
up is people look at what joe manchin
did he held the line he didn't allow
himself to get bullied kristen sigma
didn't allow himself to get bullied they
tried to force this in before these
elections now joe manchin holds the keys
to the democratic party you got people
that are coming up in these purple areas
in these purple districts and they're
looking at joe manchin saying man he's
got a point joe manchin could run this
party if he really wants to joe manchin
is the guy that says all right now you
guys come to me i think he realizes that
he wants it i really do it's the shadow
speaker of the house the third point i
have on this is that man i love how much
immigrants love this freaking country
man this is something the republican
party screwed up with for 40 freaking
years with their hard line against
immigration you look at what winston
sears is you look what pat is you look
at what people are man and they come to
this country and they're willing to
fight for this country i would love like
israel has the birthright where you want
to go to israel we should have a
birthright you want to be a communist
you get two years in any economy in this
country that you want we'll buy you the
ticket there you buy the ticket back all
right you want to be a commie birthright
birthright here you go 2 000 american
tax dollars enjoy venezuela for two
years come on back and let's have a
conversation that was pitbull's message
at his concert about a month ago you see
that no yeah pitbull talking to the
crowd the ufc fighter with the long hair
too uh
the same thing yeah so so let me go back
to the question here because this this
is the part i'm curious what you guys
because he took it there and we went a
little bit but we didn't fully go there
so trump three days ago said this guy's
gonna make a great governor he flat out
said it so that is a form of an
endorsement then they had a call
yesterday after winning and and of
course he's playing the card of listen
this is about virginia this is not about
trump i'm just trying to do this to win
this i'm here for the state
does trump's endorsement mean today what
it meant three years ago yes do you
think it still means stronger i think
you're stronger i don't i don't i don't
say no i'm gonna say stronger i'm gonna
say no we're tired of it i i'm seriously
i mean i wasn't you know i was in favor
of what he did as president but i'm not
signing up for another four years i
think there's a better alternative no no
there's not there's not but but
what we're failing to understand is that
when
pat pat said something very true uh a
while back he says when you go too far
left it creates a far right when you go
too far right it creates a far left
right
so what happened is that right now bro
there's people still with trump flags
people there's there's boat rallies he
just had one yes his words still carried
away maybe not with you but i'll tell
you one thing and i don't care and i'll
say that it carries great with me
because if you endorse somebody i'm like
hey bro you were in the office you dealt
with these guys more than i did if
you're thinking that's direction that's
the direction by the way i don't agree
with everything because he created the
vaccine i'm not i'm not antibiotic but
let me tell you something you
as as sincere and as
heartfelt as you are you might be
literally the most irrelevant voter in
america what do you mean you're
a republican in california you carry
zero weight you can't even win your
state
the fact that you love trump is
irrelevant trump california ain't going
to trump no you can't you can't get
gavin newsom out of office and everyone
hates him
your opinion is great in
glendale or wherever you live
bakersfield
it's it's irrelevant the fact that you
love trump you need someone like tom to
say
i'm back on the trump train baby you
need someone like me saying you know
what this guy [ __ ] poopy pants
fighting i can't do it again right trump
ain't gonna do it homie and that's why
i'm saying your opinion is irrelevant i
think you're wrong i just think you're
wrong
how do you have boat rallies i have
three hundred dollars worth of [ __ ]
quarters
ricky you're wrong
and i need 700 pesos more buddy you just
did a rally did you hear the deal that
we did by the way you didn't hear about
the deal with it you've seen that
ricky's pointing his car for sale yeah
and he's been riding around on horses
okay so he you know he's complaining
about gas prices and inflation and i
said ricky i'm gonna do your favor you
know the shipping crisis and supply
crisis supply chain i did it i said
ricky i'm gonna do it i'm gonna take
your car off your hand it's fine i got
you i'll pay the shipping fees i'll pay
the gas three bucks here in florida
thank you i'll pay for the shipping you
just ride your horse around in
bakersfield we'll be okay and i'll spot
you the 700 extra dollars so you don't
have to worry about it so we'll call
ourselves even but i just so i'll just
send bricks just send the new mercedes
over here to facebook let me just say
this one point i i think trump is a
release for people that are so fed up
with some of the crap that's going on so
he goes and does a rally where he knows
he's going to be embraced and he still
is a brand but i think the times call
for a very serious politician of course
and somebody that really really has the
best entrance of the country at the
heart and is smart and strategic and has
a proven track record and it's probably
leaning towards the goals realize how
much sense tom zenner is making these
days hold on so tom has been
indoctrinated into the common sense hold
on hold on so so the highest stock
market in
american history lowest unemployment
right now the current highest stock
market in american history because of
place today inflation without inflation
the highest stock market in american
history the lowest unemployment in
american history energy independent
lower tensions with russia and uh in
north korea that's not a track record
look i i'm just saying but there's but
there's the other side of that which
divides the country and someone else can
do what he does
in a different style and way other
presidents haven't done it
well to me this is what it comes down to
i look at facts 44 other presidents
haven't done it let me let me let me
you're the most irrelevant voter in
america
congratulations it's not about being
irrelevant it reminds me of the factions
back in the day with like jerry falwell
and stuff like that where you'd have to
go get the evangelical faction right the
the
desantis voter let's say right every
single trump guy they can they can you
know yell scream every single trump guy
would vote for december 100
there are people who voted for biden who
would vote for desantis there's not a
single not a one single biden voter who
would vote for trump yeah no no i so
do you understand what he just said that
i get but you're not understanding what
i'm telling you i'm not a trump guy
okay sure no but i'm not i i like what
he did because i look at the fact i
think it was necessary as well he worked
he was
he's not my savior i hustled i was
slaying
weed when george bush was president
allegedly allegedly when i was 13 like i
don't need a man to fix my life but what
i'm saying is to say that he didn't do a
good job with this country it's
completely ignorant
it didn't say that he did only did a bad
job would be naive but to say he only
did a good job would be nice i'm not
telling you that there's like there's a
gray area there
i'm not telling you that's not the case
but in 44 presidents haven't been able
to do what he did what do you mean 44
presidents
has another president been able to do
that i'm talking about specific topics
i'm not talking about
he's the best human being in the world
lowest unemployment in american history
has never been done no not lowest in
history the lowest in 50 years no
and if you look at it especially with
the hispanic the black
communities it was the lowest in history
so what i'm telling you is this when you
look at the facts and you compare if i
have to go between biden or trump but
now if there's a descendants in the mix
of course the sense is going to be the
because he's going to win over people
more but right now we're not we're not
there we're so extreme on both sides
pray that your the republican parties
nominate someone like the sanctions
by the way
nobody wants a republican or a democrat
they can't even gain five percent of the
vote but i didn't hear what you just if
the rock ran what did you say i said how
useless is my libertarian party that in
an era where literally nobody wants to
vote republican or democrat they can't
even counter because they don't have a
marketable candidate that's that's all
they don't have a market well you guys
have run joe jorgensen and gary johnson
over the last uh i like gary johnson but
yeah you like gary johnson i did like
gary johnson all right so i got a uh
okay yeah this is a good time to do it
and then we'll do the ps5 if you want to
do that we got a special surprise here
for everybody before we wrap this up
uh and while you're doing that while
you're doing that do we have time to go
into the story the the
uh the story that tom and adam give us
two minutes give us two minutes sambel
this is a story that we have to verify
this happened or not so
uh this is not a snopes story this is a
guardian gazette story biden reportedly
pooped his pants at the vatican
reports are broken out from the state uh
that state joe biden pooped himself
while meeting up with pope francis
rumors have been floating around that uh
rome that biden unusual long meeting
with the pope wasn't because the two
were best friends but rather was a
result of biden having an accident
according to american journalist jack
posabic
the live stream of biden and the pope
meeting was suddenly cut off when the
two met which raised many speculations i
was noted by the other sources on the
ground in rome that biden had a bathroom
accident
after the news broke out users on
twitter created memes and even had
poopypants biden trending on twitter
other users pointed out that biden had
different pants after meeting the pope
then he had on before meeting the pope
according to alex jones the host at
infowars secret service frequently
reported biden soiled himself jones
reported on biden uh being unable to
control bowel movements came two weeks
ago but now it looks like his reporting
isn't a conspiracy after all after
alleged accident biden looked very lost
as world leaders gathered together at
the g20 rome summit photo biden was
lined up all the way to the left usually
the u.s president stands in the middle
but biden isolated himself from
everybody and chose to stand off to the
side do you think this happened so hurt
i don't show her i i just
i'm not even gonna give an opinion here
i'm just gonna give i've watched both
uh cnn msnbc cover this and i watched
fox news and apparently this guardian
it just it amplifies how polar opposites
we are living in in this world right now
on one hand they're they're showing
images of biden
um and the pope getting along best of
friends look at these guys they
juxtaposed that with how upset the pope
was with trump or didn't have a smiley
face on they're basically
showing how all right they're best of
friends that's great and then you turn
on sides happen both sides exactly and
then you turn on to the conservative
media and it's like my [ __ ] is pants it
happened facts yeah he can't he can't he
can't control himself it's dizzy it's
pimp it's like dizzy from spin here so
you know the guys go ahead be be
children and comment on this story go
ahead do do you think go ahead children
that it is the adam scott's calling
people children that's hilarious the do
you think that it's a bad thing that
it's completely and totally plausible
yes whether it happened or not right do
you think it's a bad thing that is
completely and totally plausible that
the leader of the free world [ __ ] his
parents in front of them there isn't one
person that doesn't think that is
probably how did it happen we don't know
that's like saying do you think trump
got pissed on by a bunch of uh
prostitutes it's not like saying that at
all because i think that's actually more
likely
trump getting pissed off
by a bunch of prosecutors he's very
lucky but i'm not heard about it you're
heard about it about it first of all i'm
just saying that their feelings are hurt
in all fairness i'm good it all has zero
relevance
in all fairness to poopy joe they hear
you have not sent cast the first stone i
i've i've pooped my pants unbelievable
there it is there's the short clip right
now giardia's full on admitting that
he's a booby pant here's the deal it
wasn't when i was uh dressed in i had
the flu and i was stuck in
bumper-to-bumper traffic on the new
jersey turnpike and i had literally no
other options i wasn't so excited to see
the pope that i [ __ ] myself but you know
maybe i don't know i i don't know like
maybe who's the superstar maybe if i
maybe if i got a chance to meet johnny
bench i'd [ __ ] myself too i i i i don't
know like maybe
this is where we're at right now he who
have not said exactly this is where
we're at right now that the leader of
the free world met the leader of one of
the largest religious sects in the world
and was like
maybe and it's completely plausible yeah
i think and then you and then you took a
page out of his book and admitted that
you do the same hey may he who have not
said me
every infant on earth pat's new puppy
and the president united states we just
let it fly
i saw shits and giggles bro
it's all shits and giggles until
somebody giggles and shits themselves
right it hurts yeah it's all it's all
[ __ ] come on man
[Music]
it's okay though no mean tweets though
no mean tweets so you know orange man is
still bad that's the
truth
you're never gonna alleviate this is the
story i think it's a metaphor for his
presidency
you know i think it's
as virginia goes the rest of the country
goes adam you why does this why does
this bother you so much
i just think very clearly i think it's
like we're having so many intellectual
conversations we're actually having a
good debate and it's like let's let's
end with a [ __ ] story yeah you don't
think it's weird that everybody in the
world literally believes that yeah this
guy could have shut him back here's
here's the biggest hyperbolic everybody
in the world
we all think it probably did happen but
why can't you just excuse yourself and
go find a restroom for god's sake don't
you think that probably never happened
well number eight how do you use the
restaurant number two i have a problem
with the [ __ ] in a car like gerard i
have a problem with him nodding off you
know at that other meeting i mean take
this that is actually true i have a
bigger problem no kidding but it's a
it's a metaphor for everything every day
there's something about him that just
doesn't seem presidential and we're the
ones that are suffering because of it as
a country what am i doing here didn't
they say that literally about trump
every day doesn't seem presidential i'm
going to be so presidential when i get
elected who's they yeah
this goes back to my point you're right
we get biden and trump out of office to
get someone actually credible in there
stop it with the traffic i need you i
need you to admit right now on air that
the guy you voted for [ __ ] himself
i'll admit that you just admitted that
you [ __ ] yourself on the regular you've
never [ __ ] yourself not since i'm a
grown-up really i was four years old
maybe one time you've never proved yeah
not a heavy shirt this guy's not all
that too happy this is where we're at
right now this is your topic this is
where we're at right now all right so
this is great can we get some pampers
for gerard and joe biden while we're at
it look this seems to be quite the [ __ ]
show
there you go kai's officially comedian
good kada was impressive good for you
okay all right so let's do the last one
here and then uh let's do the cake first
okay bring it in here let's take a look
at this cake yes i haven't seen the cake
yet myself by the way so 100 episode
cake let's see what this thing looks
like
who made it is this this one that adam
made or uh
it actually does look legit wow nice job
i like it adam what do you think that's
phenomenal happy birthday to us
happy birthday poopy pants
happy
birthday here dear pod pbd
let's do 100 thank you
mickey wow that is a beautiful cake
this this is the 100th episode the next
one that we're going to celebrate at
first level you know which one's going
to be the additional 0.
is it 500 or a thousand is it 500 i
think you could celebrate five okay
we'll do it we'll do 500 we'll celebrate
go put that put the
do it let's see what's going to happen
here we couldn't have caroline do this
for the views how did sam get this job
unbelievable yeah
the fact that sam isn't wearing a vest
on the 100th episode is actually
disrespectful extremely
extremely
podcast in the beginning nobody cares
about that but they care about his best
really sam hill put it together by the
way sam bring your haircut let's see if
we can get thumbs up or down come show
your haircut everybody he says he got
the ronaldo haircut can you show it to
everybody let them see it go a little
lower you need light look straight at
the camera look straight at the camera
okay
ladies he is not single okay
oh
is that official now oh my god what's up
sam you are single or no yes you are oh
whoa yes or no
what's happening
yes or no
okay complicated translation she listens
to the podcast
let's say hey let's sing happy birthday
and then give away the plus the
playstation 5 it's the 100 uh episode
that we're doing because i think i don't
know how long has it been is it your
what's the first podcast by the way
july i'm assuming yeah july i think you
guys started last year wow okay shout
out to our old friend jf
josh who loves you by the way comments
about your stuff all the time on three
one two three happy birthday
to you happy birthday to you happy
birthday dear podcast happy birthday to
you yes go ahead you want to blow or you
want to do this uh by yourself
am i blonde we're going to blow it here
bring it over here hi this was fantastic
all right so we did uh we did joe biden
now we're doing kamala harris
all right there you go nice fantastic
guys here's to another hundred here's to
another 500 here so another thousand
good job where's willie
this was great this was fantastic tom
tom gerard ricky adam the last thing we
got to do is samvell come and tell us
and show us who's going to win the
playstation 5. this is your last chance
folks by the way a lot of good comments
here tonight about what uh today
about what the podcast is doing a couple
things i do want to tell you guys while
we're going through this we are in the
process of buying a building we were
going to buy two buildings one of the
offers the other guy came in and closed
i don't know what it was at 459 and if
that offer was gonna drop we're gonna
buy this building at 15 million bucks
but we did end up buying another
building and the new podcast set will be
coming out here soon pending a glass
showing up from china
which is a whole different count
literally
but
one of the things we're thinking about
doing with the podcast is we're gonna
set up the a podcast set in a way where
we may do a live podcast once a month
where people can buy a ticket come and
actually watch the podcast live i think
would be real sick to have an audience
there doing it together and then uh we
may be going to three episodes a week
the key word in that sentence is a very
technical word it's man
and what we are talking what it means is
in
[Laughter]
but the biggest thing is we may test out
doing two the tuesday thursday episode
we may test out a friday afternoon
episode
for uh just to see how that's going to
do it it's going to be three or five or
four to six we don't know yet but we may
test out something that's going to be on
a friday afternoon go ahead gerard let
me ask you before you wrap up the
your your 100 episodes in is this has
this turned into what you expected it to
be what have you learned along the way
has the audience you've been there like
what yeah what's this experience for you
let me tell you what what i love about
what what happened tom you good nothing
you were making some weird noises no
it's like happy trails right what was
the journey but no no i will tell you
this that's a great question i will tell
you that what what this has done the
podcast has done is it is created an
open platform for us to talk about real
issues that people are thinking about
but you're told by society that you
shouldn't talk about these things i like
talking about
stuff that people don't want to talk
about i'm interested in that and i think
these things we talk about there's an
audience for it the most important thing
about what we're doing is the fact that
there's an audience that wants to hear
this kind of discourse from a former you
know ricky aguilar who lived a different
life michoacan to now being a successful
businessman he and his wife run a very
successful multi-multi-million dollar
year business for themselves from a
former comedian kirk he's still a
comedian but a guy that worked on chris
christie's camp was a former
professional athlete fighter mlb
sitting here from jersey you bring in
your opinions there tom zenner who every
time you talk to tom you learn something
new about the guy he was there for the
last dance at every single day you know
married guy with two kids from
california tom ellsworth who's been in
the uh
you know different industries with tech
has had many different successes strong
father strong family from a you know a
devout jewish handsome man who is a cat
supporter cat convention you know out
here was thinking about getting married
before 70 years old who has his own
strong opinions
we're working on you are not working on
that man listen i am working on that
i i would put over under what that i
would actually put some money on the
over under for age i would put some real
money and if the wedding happens if i
lose i fund your entire wedding how
about that if if i will i will fund your
entire wedding if i get the age right
okay
he'd get married right now what are you
what are you ready for the party
you're 40 right now yeah you get married
before 43 i pay for your wedding i'm the
type of guy that would get married just
to save that money
you get married asap i do your wedding i
do it at the house i'll bring ya so i'll
do anything you want for you
now you're talking my language man
ladies out there
can you imagine he actually gets married
before 43 and i'm at the wedding i'm
giving a speech i'm like listen i funded
this i made the biggest mistake saying
yes but anyways worst investment but
here's the thing everybody hang on a
second if it's after 43 then what what
do i get because that's what you got to
say to the public as well if it's after
43.
i only like one side of this equipment
it's not how this works
if it's not 43 what is it i guess i got
to fund my own wedding
we got let's i'm a risk i got a risk
here because to me if you get i pay for
dylan's wedding when he when he grows up
i'll have time to work on he's gonna be
pretty big but he's middle eastern it's
gonna be like 600 thousand dollars
yeah okay all right so uh anyway who do
you think gets married first gerard or
me
or dylan
right
there we go
[Laughter]
dylan ah
who do i think between you and him
i'm probably going gerard yeah really
yeah i am but but for different reasons
i'm going with gerrard okay and i don't
think neither one of you guys want to
get married at any time you do want to
get i would put your money on me over
gerard i don't know i don't know
someone's gonna have to agree to marry
that guy you gotta understand i think
there's a there's a line i think there's
there's plenty of cat man
here's that case study time baby
all right bust out that uh trying on
that calculator we're gonna put some
degrees on this side i guarantee i just
can't i can't guarantee you he's done
more research on that than you have yeah
i guarantee you he has the field
research predictive analytics at seven
minutes and forty eight seconds
the biz dog has pulled it off the biz
dog babe is dope she's great she's cool
you out kicked your coverage buddy nice
respect fyi every night his kids call
him just to talk to him before he goes
to sleep no matter what part of the
world is in this guy's a winner at the
highest level yeah
i tell you one other thing about this
whole uh this whole uh uh thing with the
podcast is you
don't have to interview
somebody that's like it's just we're
coming together as friends and having
conversations together okay what are you
thinking about it so uh pretty excited
about the next thing we're doing some of
the uh announcements that we'll be
making here soon going to be exciting
but this is where we release can we give
a shout out to the production team over
here eric david jorge they did a great
job
they did a great job like sam made it
happen today six of us i know they put a
lot of work in here i got a shout out
today paul got a shout out for the fish
tom gave you a nice little shout out
about you
bring your fish but yeah
team did a great job everybody did a
great job thank you for your help having
said that let's do the last raffle we
got the playstation 5 here
and by the way uh people want the whole
thing to be signed so we'll all sign it
with a sharpie and send it out to you so
you already have it oh it's going
already
oh
gerard wins this thing how sick are the
valuetainers man look at this thing
lisa h won the playstation
uh uh playstation of five is going to
lisa h
uh uh hopefully you wanted this
playstation's coming to you if you
didn't want the playstation somebody you
know very closely
is gonna be very happy that you're
getting this fyi it's gonna be pretty
hard to find this we had a hard time
finding this we had to kind of buy it to
i don't know how we've been working
13 you can't find it no no we got it but
our audience is getting it so pretty
happy to see this taking place uh gang
having said this this is the hundredth
episode officially coming to an end the
next one we'll be doing are we doing
podcast next next tuesday am i in town
next tuesday or no
next tuesday we are doing podcast next
tuesday have a wonderful weekend
everybody subscribe to the channel and
looking forward to seeing you guys next
tuesday take care everybody bye bye bye
bye
you